c'est parti allez on sait pas lire on
n'est pas bête mais enfin je suis pas
très loin de la Belgique quand même
mes chers collègues si vous le voulez
bien donc nous allons démarrer cette
audition
alors nous avons
autour de donc pour cette audition la
Table Ronde des élus locaux pour
laquelle nous avons en présentiel madame
rossignol qui est notre première
vice-présidente de la Fédération
nationale des scottes monsieur Sébastien
Miossec président délégué
intercommunalité de France bienvenue et
merci de vous être rendu disponible et
là je m'adresse à la visio et
normalement nous devrions avoir en
visioconférence si tout va bien
Monsieur
Jean-François débat maire de
Bourg-en-Bresse et président de grands
bourre agglomération qui représente
l'Association des maires de France et
des présidents d'intercommunalité
donc je pense qu'il est là est-ce qu'il
est là il y a Monsieur François
descoeurs et Monsieur Sébastien
gouttebelle
donc Sébastien gouttebelle et Monsieur
desker pour les communes rurales
à Mrs
je vois monsieur gouttebelle qui
s'affiche bonjour monsieur gouttebelle
il nous manque personne monsieur Decker
même chose
donc il nous manque qui monsieur
débarque
on va attendre
on démarre et puis monsieur débat
prendra
en cours de route bon toute façon je
vais faire un petit propos liminaire
pour resituer le sujet donc chers
collègues après deux auditions plénières
qui ont donné lieu à des échanges précis
et fournis avec régions de France ainsi
que les ministres Béchu et forts notre
audition du jour est consacrée au
déploiement de la stratégie zéro
artificialisation nette au plus près des
territoires et à son appropriation par
les acteurs de proximité
si l'État et les régions ont par
construction des approches macro fondées
sur des appréciations d'ensemble et des
données agrégées n'oublions pas que la
différenciation territoriale en matière
de trajectoire foncière se déclinera au
niveau des scottes et du bloc communal
les régions ont peut-être été désignées
chefs de fil du zan mais en bout de
chaîne ce sont les communes EPC qui
devront atteindre leurs objectifs de
réduction et réaliser les arbitrages
difficiles le 13 octobre dernier la
mission conjointe de contrôle du Sénat
avait déjà entendu les associations
représentatives des élus locaux ainsi
que la fn Scott il s'agissait à l'époque
d'un travail exploratoire
visant à recueillir les premiers retours
sur sa mise sur la mise en application
du Zen l'exercice est aujourd'hui
quelques peu différents puisque nous
avons depuis lors déposer une
proposition de loi sénatoriale issues de
nos travaux notre texte vise à apporter
certaines des solutions et outils
demandées par certains élus mais tout en
restant de dans le cadre fixé par la loi
votée en 2021 qui prévoit la réduction
de moitié du rythme d'artificialisation
d'ici à 2031 et l'absence
d'artificialisation nette en 2050 le
Sénat constitue une commission spéciale
chargée d'examiner ce texte le 8 mars
prochain nous présenterons un texte de
commission qui sera ensuite examiné en
séance publique le 14 mars il ne s'agit
donc plus de rédiger un texte en partant
d'une feuille blanche mais de recueillir
l'analyse des élus du bloc communal et
de la Fédération nationale des Scott sur
les dispositions du texte article par
article afin éventuellement d'y apporter
des ajustements nous savons qu'il nous
faut trouver des équilibres parfois
complexes afin de garantir d'une part
que la loi sera appliquée de manière
équitable et qu'elle n'est pas d'effet
de bord délétère et d'autre part de
s'assurer qu'elles restent claire et
simple d'application pour les élus
concernés au premier rang la proposition
de loi sénatoriale comporte plusieurs
articles qui concernent directement les
élus locaux et intercommunaux elle
modifie par exemple le Caleb calendrier
d'évolution des stradettes et en cascade
le délai de modification des documents
d'urbanisme locaux Scott pluie et carte
communale elle vise aussi à trouver des
modes de concertation plus équilibrées
entre différents niveaux de
collectivités territoriales en proposant
notamment la création d'une conférence
régionale de gouvernance d'usane elle
prévoit également de réserver une partie
de l'enveloppe régionale
d'artificialisation au profit d'un droit
minimal zan d'un hectare pour chaque
commune d'une part et la prise en compte
de projets supracommunaux d'autre part
elle met enfin à disposition des élus
des outils pour contrer la ruée vers le
foncier que l'on observe déjà avec un
sursis à statuer spécifique et un droit
de préemption sur les espaces propices à
la saturation et au recyclage fonciers
nous vous remercions donc d'avoir
répondu à notre invitation pour évoquer
ces différents points en vue de l'examen
prochain du texte et comme je vous l'ai
rappelé les personnes présentes
aujourd'hui sont les représentants donc
monsieur débat qui s'est
joint à nous pas encore je n'ai pas vu
donc monsieur débat monsieur Gouttebel
monsieur Baker monsieur Miossec et
Madame Rossignol je sais tout d'abord la
parole pour un propos liminaire que je
vous demanderai de bien vouloir limiter
à 5 minutes chacun afin de laisser le
temps échanges puis notre rapporteur
Jean-Baptiste blanc vous posera deux
séries de questions auxquelles nous vous
prierons de répondre successivement et
enfin nous procéderons un échange de
questions-réponses avec nos collègues de
la commission spéciale voilà comment
s'organisera donc cette séance et sans
plus attendre je propose donc à nos
invités et bien de tenir pour chacun de
leurs organismes un propos de cinq
minutes
madame Rossignol Honor à vous vous
démarrez la série
madame la première vice-présidente à
vous la parole merci beaucoup de
apporter au travail pour mener les
conférences de scotch
diversité de nos régions mais un travail
extrêmement important qui a été menée
par l'ensemble des conférences des
scottes surtout les territoires et que
ça n'était pas gagné d'avance puisque
finalement il nous fallait
travailler son cadre réglementaire
et qu'il fallait inventer des modes de
fonctionnement des modes de
d'avancer vers des consensus les plus
abouties possibles
et que finalement le bloc communal tenu
le Paris et que toutes les régions ont
rendu des documents
divers mais que preuve a été faite que
donner confiance au territoire
était un pari gagnant je pense que ça
c'est la première chose et que
ce sang
engagés de vrais dynamiques sur les
territoires que souvent les scottes en
particulier des nouvelles régions
n'avaient pratiquement jamais travaillé
ensemble et qu'aujourd'hui il se
connaissent et ont dégagé des méthodes
de travail que pour beaucoup d'entre eux
ils poursuivent de façon
en ayant créé des commissions en
approfondissant un certain nombre de
questions de leurs propres initiative ou
à la demande de la région sur certaines
questions et que donc il y a une vraie
dynamique de travail qui s'est engagé et
qui est positive alors par rapport au
texte
les points principaux sur lesquels nous
voulons insister c'est que la conférence
de gouvernance régionale elle doit tenir
compte du travail qui a été fait par ses
conférences de scotch et que les scottes
qui sont les représentants du bloc
communal doivent y trouver toute leur
place et que l'expérience de travail
qu'ils ont mené doit être prise en
compte et valoriser dans dans ses
conférences de gouvernance le deuxième
point sur lequel je voudrais insister
c'est la question des grands projets
d'envergure régional et européenne alors
bon je suis issue des Hauts de France et
donc
c'est l'exemple
symptomatique puisque mais qui se
retrouvent dans bien d'autres régions
puisque si les grands projets
d'envergure national et européenne ne
sont pas prises en compte dans une
enveloppe spécifique nationale c'est 85%
de l'enveloppe régionale qui sera
consommée par ses grands projets autant
dire que nous nous partagerons quasiment
rien et que donc toute la méthode de
travail et l'objectif même de la loi se
trouverait remis en cause
la question de la surface minimale d'un
hectare c'est finalement la question de
la prise en compte des territoires
ruraux qui ont peu ou pas consommé
ils ne nous semble pas que la question
de que la possibilité de donner un
hectare par commune soit quelque chose
qui soit opérationnel et qui permettent
de créer une dynamique en termes
d'utilisation de nos de nos capacités
artificialiser en tout cas jusqu'en 2031
parce que finalement la question c'est
de donner la possibilité à tout
territoire de pouvoir
consommer de la terre
des hénafes de la terre agricole dans le
cas où elle a un projet qui le justifie
mais en même temps de ne pas donner des
droits
artificialiser à des territoires qui ne
les utiliseraient pas et que la question
de la dynamique de du maintien de la
dynamique économique tout en assurant
une équité et la question que ce sont
posées de très nombreuses conférences de
Scott mais il ne semble pas que
l'hectare à toutes les communes alors on
pourrait même dire il y a certaines
communes qui n'ont qui n'ont pas un
acteur de construire aujourd'hui
et donc ce côté mécanique et artificiel
d'une égalité
apparente ne nous paraît pas la bonne
solution il me semble qu'il faut donner
et il y a plusieurs suggestions dans
différents territoires
vous pourriez peut-être au fur et à
mesure et ça vaut peut-être pour tous
les toutes les personnes qui vont
intervenir quand vous soulevez un sujet
ce que vous pouvez nous donner des
propositions alternatives en même temps
que vous les évoquez ça peut être utile
et gagner du temps au travers de
l'exposition
dans les hauts de France mais je dis il
y a plusieurs
il y a plusieurs hypothèses qui ont été
soulevées mais par exemple dans les
hauts de France nous nous sommes dit que
il nous fallait une enveloppe régionale
consacrée à ces territoires qui qui soit
qui ont été particulièrement vertueux
soit qui n'ont pas consommé pour des
raisons
circonstancielle
d'absence de développement août ou
circonstancielle ils n'ont pas consommé
mais ils doivent pouvoir avoir un droit
consommer mais qui serait globalisé de
manière à ce qu'il soit utilisé de la
façon la plus efficace possible
et de moins pénaliser les territoires
dynamiques qui ont besoin qui sont
créateurs d'emploi qui attirent de la
population et qui ont un besoin
essentiel de
consommer ça ça a été dans les hauts de
France a été un sujet extrêmement
important qui sur lequel nous avons
auquel nous avons consacré plusieurs
conférences des scottes bon il y a
d'autres solutions qui ont pu être
envisagées mais c'en est une la question
des surfaces végétalisées nous laissent
c'est l'article 9 nous laisse assez
dubitatif
quant à
il nous semble qu'il sera qu'il serait
indispensable que les zones à densifier
alors la question de l'article 9 c'est
que finalement des zones non
artificialisées à l'intérieur des
périmètres urbains pourraient se trouver
interdite de densification et
d'artificialisation et qui nous semble
que les Scott devront devrait
indiquer quelles sont les zones qui sur
lesquelles on pourrait envisager de
densifier et les zones sur lesquelles il
faudrait garder
les zones non artificialisées et que les
plus rentreraient ensuite ou les pays
rentreraient ensuite dans cette logique
si on si on garde le le quadrillage
prévu
on risque d'interdire le la
densification dans les zones urbaines
le contre ce qui va contrebalancer
l'absence d'artificialisation c'est bien
la densification et donc où va-t-on
densifier comment va-t-on densifier ça
nous paraît une question importante
la question de l'observation
il nous semble que aujourd'hui il n'y a
pas de
je suis très rapide mais aujourd'hui il
n'y a pas
d'observation admise d'outils
d'observation
incontestables et admis partout
et il nous semble donc qu'il y devrait y
avoir une démarche contradictoire au
niveau de chaque territoire pour établir
le chiffre 0 de l'artificialisation et
pour ensuite prendre en compte ce qui
s'artificialise ou ce qui ne
certificatise pas
sur l'article 12 on a une question sur
le sursis à statuer
et le droit de préemption effectivement
si nous n'avons aucun outil
jusqu'à la fin de la révision des pluies
pour interdire ou
certaines
artificialisations comment peut-on
travailler et c'est une question qui se
pose aussi par rapport
à l'hypothèse de rallonger les délais
comment fait-on nous ce qui nous semble
plus important puisque en termes de
c'est que les territoires puissent le
plus rapidement possible s'engager dans
la réflexion sur un nouveau modèle et de
nouveaux modèles d'aménagement il y a
que globalement la conférence des
scottes partage bien l'objectif de la
loi et l'idée c'est comment pouvons-nous
inventer un nouveau modèle
qui permettent de maintenir du dynamisme
économique et de dynamisme de nos
territoires mais sur sur un modèle
différent et que
prolonger trop longtemps cette période
dans laquelle nous n'aurions aucun moyen
d'action puisque c'est le cas
aujourd'hui le décompte a commencé mais
nous n'avons pas de moyens d'action nos
terrains sont constructibles on voit
bien une spéculation qui commence très
fortement
à se mettre en route ou qui est déjà
mise en route dès qu'on a entendu parler
de la loi et donc il nous faut des
outils pour pouvoir
contrôler et mettre en œuvre un nouveau
modèle
sur l'article sur l'article 13 je crois
que donc l'article 12 c'est le et
l'article 13 la rue maturation c'est
toute la question de la définition de la
renaturation et des conditions du modèle
économique
voilà pour les points principaux en 5
minutes donc j'ai essayé d'être
extrêmement rapide
[Musique]
sans plus attendre le jeu laisse la
parole à Monsieur débat dont je pense
enfin qui je pense est
pris par une autre oblig donc monsieur
débat je vous cède tout de suite la
parole si vous le voulez bien merci
madame la Présidente avec mes excuses
pour le retard avec lequel je me suis
connecté et avec mes remerciements de
pouvoir me permettre d'intervenir au nom
de l'Association des maires de France
maintenant en effet à 17h je me trouve
actuellement à Bercy parce qu'à 17h nous
rencontrons le ministre Bruno Le Maire
et donc c'était la possibilité pour moi
de faire de lier les deux engagements
malgré la le faible écart de temps j'ai
néanmoins entendu une partie de ce qu'a
dit l'intervenant de précédente au nom
de la situation des maires de France
puisque j'ai compris que il y avait un
certain nombre d'observation que nous
faisions à titreliminaire mais je n'en
ferai pas d'autres donc je me propose de
d'organiser ça en deux de courtes
parties la première c'est de dire ce qui
dans le projet la proposition de loi
sénatoriale nous convient et va dans le
bon sens sous le bénéfice peut-être de
quelques ajustements rédactionnels mais
qui correspond à des objectifs que nous
poursuivons et puis d'évoquer les
quelques sujets sur lesquels nous avons
des points de vue différents voir et des
interrogations d'abord d'une manière
générale
nous la situation des maires de France
s'inscrit dans la mise en œuvre du zan
parce que nous ont partageons tous les
objectifs et donc il ne faut pas en
affadir la mise en œuvre dans la
proposition de loi
propose du Sénat certains aspects donc
je vais les évoquer très rapidement nous
paraissent aller dans le bon sens et
donc ne mérite pas de développement très
important la prolongation d'un an du
calendrier d'estradettes
correspond à un élément de réalité donc
le repousser d'un an ne nous pose pas de
difficultés étant observé quand même que
si on suit je dirais les procédures
habituelles de révision des stradettes
puis de celle des squats puissent être
des on risque de se trouver en 2028 29
au début de la mise en œuvre ou en tout
cas pas avant 2028 au début de la mise
en oeuvre ce qui lui par rapport à un
objectif décennale de 2031 poserait
difficulté et donc il est important
quand même que
la période dite sera dette ne dure pas
trop longtemps le deuxième élément c'est
que si sera dates il doit y avoir il
nous faut respecter la loi initiale et
non pas les décrets actuels en Conseil
d'État qui font que la le rapport
juridique entre le stradet d'une part et
les scottes et plu et c'est une simple
prise en compte et non une mise en
compatibilité en effet il ne nous semble
pas que cette austradette de déterminer
les secteurs dans lesquels on devrait
densifier ou pas dans lesquels on
devrait conserver du foncier ou pas et
que ceci relève bien dans tous les
territoires couverts par des scottes
ceux sur lesquels il y a le plus
d'enjeux des scottes eux-mêmes qui sont
de les lieux de mise en oeuvre
principaux de la loi qui sont maîtrisés
par les élus locaux dans lequel ni les
élus urbains très élu ruraux ne sont
automatiquement majoritaires et qui
correspondent au lieu de mise en oeuvre
du territoire donc pour les stradettes
oui mais vite et pas prescriptif dans le
sens d'une commise en compatibilité
la prise en compte de la renaturation
des efforts de renaturation dès 2021 est
un oubli de la loi donc initiale donc
elle va dans le bon sens la question des
des projets d'envergure nationale et
européenne il a il y a une chose qui est
certaine pour la situation des maires de
France elle ne peut pas peser uniquement
sur les régions dans lesquelles ces
projets sont organisés et donc nous soit
il y a une péréquation soit on les
ajoute à ceci près que tout dépend de
leur ampleur si ces quatre pour cent du
total
les ajouter ne perturbent pas
considérablement la mise en oeuvre du
zan si c'est 20% c'est un autre sujet ce
qui est important pour nous c'est que le
gouvernement mettent en transparence
quelles sont ses projets de manière à ce
que les choses soient connues et que les
règles de de répartition de péréquation
si elles sont mises en oeuvre soit donc
à partir de la connu et donc accepter
l'articulation des
usanne avec les projets d'intérêt
général pose une autre question qui est
celle de qui reconnaît les projets
d'intérêt général
autre que les projets d'intérêt national
ou européenne
et sur le sujet comme je l'ai dit projet
d'intérêt national ou européen nous
demandons nous souhaitons que le l'état
dise en transparence quelles sont ses
projets pour en évaluer la je dirais
l'intérêt et l'impact il ne nous paraît
pas plus juste que par exemple ce soit
seulement les régions qui déterminent
quels sont les projets d'intérêt
régional qui viendraient s'apputer sur
l'enveloppe de chaque territoire parce
que nous serions proches de la tutelle
d'une collectivité sur une autre c'est
donc nécessairement d'un processus
multi partenariale état région
Conférence régionale des squats et donc
élus locaux que la validation des
projets d'intérêt général qui sont
directs qui ont un impact significatif
par exemple à l'échelle d'une région
doivent être arrêtés on ne peut pas
imaginer ni que ce soit l'état seul ni
que ce soit les régions seules sans que
les élus locaux aient pu participer et
faire en sorte parce que c'est très
important que les allocations qui
viendront ensuite sur les scottes soit
équitables soit juste et ne soit pas
biaisé par des choix soit de l'État soit
des régions qui finalement
favoriseraient de fait tel territoire
par rapport à tel autre c'est un élément
très important de la de la compréhension
de la mise en oeuvre et de
l'acceptabilité du Zam
pour ce qui concerne finalement les
points sur lesquels nous avons un
certain nombre de de
questions
il je veux évoquer celui de la
celui attendez je viens oui celui
de la ce qu'on appelle la garantie
rurale qui appelle de la part de
l'Association des maires de France deux
types d'observation d'abord
les vins propositions qui ont été
adoptées par le bureau de la station des
maires de France
appelle l'attention et sur une partie
des communes rurales mais pas toutes les
communes rurales une partie des
communaux rurales celle située en Zr et
notamment en ZRR dans lesquels il y a eu
très peu de projets au cours des 10
dernières années qui feraient que pas
grand chose divisé par deux à bouthérèse
a presque rien
et pour ces pour ces territoires en ZRR
et en ZRR dans lesquels on est en
désertification dans lesquelles on est
en déshérence dans lesquelles on est en
diminution de population il nous semble
que la réponse ça n'est pas de donner
une allocation par principe de temps par
commune mais de prévoir dans la loi que
chaque Scott ou si ce n'est pas le Scott
chaque autorité qui donnera des
allocations devra permettre des projets
devra permettre une allocation
compatible avec les projets de
développement de ces communes en
revanche traiter toutes les communes
rurales n'est pas notre demande une
partie importante très importante
plusieurs milliers voire plus de
communes rurales sont aujourd'hui en
expansion démographique sont aujourd'hui
en développement démographique ce sont
même dans les territoires périurbains et
ruraux qui sont proches de
d'agglomération en gros qui sont dans
des régions ou des départements qui
eux-mêmes se développent fortement ce
sont même souvent là que l'on a le plus
développé et le plus consommé au cours
des quelques années passées ce que nous
et je voudrais attirer l'attention sur
le fait que le 1 hectare par commune
rural quel que soit sa localisation et
quel que soit son passé quel que soit sa
situation peut aboutir à des choses
aberrantes
je vais prendre l'exemple que je connais
le mieux je suis maire de
Bourg-en-Bresse président de grands
bourgs
74 communes dont une quarantaine de
communes de moins de 1000 habitants la
plus petite ayant 85 habitants et la
plus importante 45000 au cours des 10
dernières années nous avons consommé
donc de 2012 à 2021
732 hectares donc 73 hectares par an
ça c'est ce que nous avons consommé au
cours des dix dernières années
si nous devons diviser notre objectif à
peu près par 2 nous devrions être aux
environs de 35 il y a 74 communes dont
69 communes rurales ou peut-être 65 si
on est exclu les bourses ça veut bien
dire que l'allocation par principe d'un
hectare par commune aboutit à des choses
qui sont aberrantes et non compatibles
avec l'évolution des scottes c'est pour
ça que la position de la situation des
maires de France et de faire en sorte
que ce soit les scottes qui dansaient
dans ces territoires et bien procède à
la location et je le dis ici dans par
exemple mon Scott et bien les communes
rurales c'est une communauté
d'agglomération sont majoritaires donc
il y a pas de raison de penser que dans
la répartition interne entre les enjeux
d'habitat et les enjeux économiques et
les enjeux d'équilibre territorial ce
soit systématiquement les communes
rurales qui sont majoritaires qui
seraient défavorisés donc il faut que
les scottes et cette liberté en revanche
nous souhaitons une garantie pour les
territoires dans lesquels il y a
quasiment pas de consommation dans
lesquelles il doit y avoir un minimum
qui doit être qui ne peut pas être en
revanche un hectare pour chacune des 32
communes rurales de ce pays
sauf si non à compromettre complètement
à remettre en cause complètement
l'objectif même du de la réduction
d'artificialisation des sols enfin deux
éléments nous pensons que l'outre-mer
doit faire l'objet de règles
particulières liées à la particularité
de ces territoires et que les communes
qui sont concernées en métropole ou en
outre-mer notamment par le recul du
trait de côte doivent également faire
l'objet de mesures d'adaptation qui
pourront être précisées et évidemment au
cours des années voire des décennies à
venir mais pour bénéficier de
possibilités
d'artifacie d'artificialisation au fur
et à mesure qu'elles devront déplacer
leur
urbanisation et pour répondre à votre
question madame la Présidente que
proposons nous nous proposons
c'est que la loi prévoit que pour les
communes qui sont en ZRR ou en ZRR plus
c'est-à-dire celle dans lesquelles la
consommation d'espace au cours des 10
dernières années a été nulle ou en
réduction de population etc
ils doivent être obligation au Scott de
prévoir une allocation compatible avec
les perspectives de développement de ces
communes de manière à ce que cette
obligation de résultats soit
soit transféré sur sur les lieux de mise
en oeuvre que sont principalement les
les squats voilà ce que je souhaitais
dire au nom de l'Association des maires
de France n'ayant probablement pas
puisque je vais écouter les autres
intervenants jusque environ 16h50
l'occasion de reprendre la parole mais
si vous aviez du coup une question ou
autre je pourrais y répondre de manière
de manière plus plus rapide je termine
sur un point des questions de
actuellement jusqu'en 2031 on ne parle
pas réellement d'artificialisation on
parle de consommation d'espaces dans les
PLU
on ne parle pas encore de la question de
savoir comment on va évaluer les terres
qui ont les pelouse qui ont été
artificialisés puis replanter
aujourd'hui c'est vraiment les enjeux de
consommation d'espace et nous nous
pensons que il faut rapidement que les
lieux de mise en œuvre principaux que
sont les scottes soit très vite saisi de
ce sujet pour que justement le temps
nécessaire au plan local pour trouver
les bons équilibres entre les
articulations développement de l'habitat
65% de la consommation moyenne de
développement économique et notamment de
rien industrialisation 25% au cours des
dernières années mais peut-être plus à
l'avenir si on veut accueillir de
nouvelles activités industrielles et
bien soit qu'on ait le temps de faire
les arbitrages pour que Lausanne ne
devienne pas une règle à calcul mais une
politique voilà ce que je souhaitais
dire madame la Présidente et mesdames et
messieurs
[Musique]
chevalet est tombé mais donc je vais me
représenter Sébastien Miossec donc
président délégué d'intercommunalité de
France je représente notre président
Sébastien Martin
donc élu d'une commune de 4000 habitants
comme une littoral couvert à un PLU un
PLU puis un P8 depuis maintenant 15
jours donc je suis à peu près tous les
tous les étapes et président d'un Scott
donc on essaie de ça permet une vue un
peu transversale et à l'expérience sur
ce propos introductif
ce qui est Satis enfin ce qui est une
bonne nouvelle dans la loi c'est que
vous le Sénat nous propose pas de
remettre en question l'objectif initial
de la loi climat résilience qui est de
d'économiser de foncier partout en
France quel que soit les territoires et
en ayant en tête toutes et tous que
c'est une dynamique qui est déjà en
place depuis y compris avant la loi
climat résilience dans beaucoup de
territoires on a on a déjà écrit dans
nos documents d'urbanisme les économies
de fonciers pour autant cette loi qui
m'a résilience a suscité beaucoup de
questions d'inquiétude d'interrogations
les assauts d'élus les parlementaires le
gouvernement on proposait un certain
nombre d'adaptation mais il s'avère que
la loi a besoin d'être corrigée sur
certains aspects donc c'est en cela que
le l'initiative du Sénat est heureuse
et aussi fait quoi notamment aux
remontée de petites communes qui sont
souvent sans document d'urbanisme et
sans cette culture de document
d'urbanisme je vais revenir dans
quelques minutes
donc il y a des choses à corriger mais
quelques impératifs sur lesquels
l'interprète France insiste donc ne pas
renoncer à l'ambition de d'économie de
fonciers pas juste par la beauté du
geste mais parce qu'il y a un impératif
climatique parce qu'on a aussi vu
partout dans le territoire et
Jean-François l'a évoqué aussi à
l'instant mais les méfaits de
l'étalement urbain par rapport à la
dynamique de nos centralités que ce soit
les villes centre ou les les bourses
mais chacune centralité à un moment de
s'éparpiller de s'étaler ça on a on en a
constaté aussi les effets négatifs et
puis l'impératif de préservation de nos
espaces naturels et agricoles notamment
et face notamment aux enjeux de nourrir
la planète et nourrir notre pays
deuxième impératif c'est de ne pas
entretenir trop longtemps le flou qui
est préjudiciable au projet au projet
qui se traduisent dans les documents
d'urbanisme qu'on a eu du stradet au
Scott au PLU intercommunaux ou communaux
mais aussi au projet d'habitat et au
projet de développement économique donc
par rapport à l'article 1 de la
proposition
plutôt une réserve sur le fait
d'allonger les délais même si
l'assouplissement ou la superposition de
certains délais pourrait permettre de
gagner du temps ce qui est une bonne
chose mais il ne faut pas que le terme
de l'histoire soit repoussé trop
longtemps on a besoin d'y voir clair le
plus vite possible de stabiliser le
contexte troisième précaution donc
éviter qu'on imagine des dispositifs qui
seraient parfois pire que pire que le
mal entre guillemets la peur qui est
souvent exprimée c'est de l'aide c'est
celle d'être empêché à se développer
faute de foncier se développer pour
attirer des habitants ou se développer
pour attirer des entreprises mais on
sait que c'est pas la vérité d'un jour
n'est pas celle du lendemain et que la
vie économique est fluctuante on a
besoin de de souplesse
et donc là pour pour interco de France
mais ça fait quoi d'autre interventions
aussi la réponse est réside plutôt dans
dans écrire et penser à un projet à
l'échelle de sa commune et de son
territoire donc ça passe plutôt par le
document d'urbanisme qui permet de
penser son avenir et préparer les
réponses puisque quand bon nombre d'élus
locaux disent ouais mais moi j'ai besoin
d'avoir une inquiétude parce que comment
ma commune va se développer à moyen et
long terme je pense que notre
responsabilité collective c'est aussi
d'encourager ses élus à écrire et penser
un projet à travers un document
d'urbanisme donc ça peut passer par une
carte communale ça passe surtout pas un
document d'urbanisme plu communal ou
plui puisque plus de la moitié des
intercommunalités plus de la moitié de
la France est couverte à une compétence
pluie cette document PMU c'est ce qui
permet d'avoir une réponse adaptée à la
réalité de ce qu'on vit aujourd'hui à
l'échelle de sa commune mais plus
souvent aujourd'hui à l'échelle de son
bassin de vie et surtout quand on fait
un PLU notamment intercommunal ça permet
de mutualiser les moyens humains et les
moyens financiers à une hauteur à une
dimension qui est celle du bassin dit
notamment face à l'état on sait tous les
difficultés de faire vivre enfin en tout
cas je l'ai vécu chez moi d'écrire un
document d'urbanisme à l'échelle d'une
seule commune quand on écrit à plusieurs
face à l'état ça permet notamment de
répondre à ces enjeux de partage du
foncier ça permet de mettre en commun le
foncier je l'évoquais et notamment de
répondre à cette difficulté que
certaines petites communes disent bah
oui mais moi aujourd'hui j'ai pas eu de
projet ces dernières années je vais en
avoir à l'avenir dans un pays lui
intercommunal document écrit par les
élus et valider dans une gouvernance qui
protège les petites communes
Jean-François debal évoquait dans dans
la quasi-totalité des intercommunalités
de France les petites communes sont
majoritaires et comme les modes de
validation des pluies
protège la majorité des des communes à
un moment c'est pour nous le meilleur la
meilleure façon de traduire le zan et de
répondre aux peurs qui sont qui sont
souvent évoqués alors tout ça demande de
la pédagogie si la moitié des
territoires de France sont couverts par
des pluies c'est pas le cas de la moitié
et souvent parce qu'il y a des blocages
et des et des réticences donc faut aussi
les les
entendre mais de notre point de vue
c'est la meilleure façon de penser de
mettre en oeuvre Lausanne et de répondre
aux enjeux de quotas de etc de de
minimum garantis parce que dans un PLU
on écrit collectivement et en respectant
l'histoire de chaque commune et y
compris là où il y a des communes il y a
pas eu de développement je pense que il
n'y aura pas ou si c'est le cas ce sera
exceptionnel des interco qui ne
donneraient rien à certaines communes
et puis c'est la meilleure façon de
mettre en oeuvre la différenciation la
décentralisation la responsabilité
locale que je pense le Sénat a pu aussi
sur les grands projets c'est le des
autres sujets on a besoin d'y voir clair
de préciser la gouvernance donc ça va
faire référence à l'article 3 dans du de
la PPL
c'est le gouvernance c'est important de
la poser
l'état puis les régions ont à poser
l'état d'abord sur les grands projets
européens ou nationaux à dire rapidement
ce qu'il entend par grand projet
nationaux européens mais à l'échelle
régionale et encore plus à l'échelle de
de la déclinaison dans les Scott on a
besoin de poser le gouvernance la
proposition qui est qui est celle du de
la PPL
nous paraît pas adapté parce qu'elle le
fige une composition la même dans toutes
les régions de France alors que les
hauts de France et la Bretagne il y en a
des configurations très différentes donc
poser un quota un nom de représentants
par région longues parait pas adapté
donc deux propositions soit de laisser à
chaque région la capacité de faire une
proposition qui s'appuie notamment sur
l'expérience des conférences des scottes
et je reçois je ce sens là madame
Rossignol sur sa proposition ou la
deuxième proposition puisqu'il y a quand
même une question de légitimité aussi
un moment si on demande à cette instance
de gouvernance de valider de choisir des
grands projets
il faut qu'elle puisse être légitime et
représentatif et à ce stade le seul
endroit dans nos régions où on a Élie
élu pendant des représentants de tous
les agents de collectivités c'est les
citer HAP malgré leur limite et je sais
qu'il y a des régions de ça ne marche
pas mais il y a d'autres régions où ça
marche plutôt bien et j'étais ce matin à
la CPAP et Bretagne qui qui marchait
plutôt qui marche plutôt bien mais je
sais que ça ne marche pas partout aussi
bien
deux trois quatre et pour être rapide
puisque j'ai largement dépassé mais cinq
minutes
sur les grands projets aussi une
attention particulière qu'on veut
souligner à interco de France c'est
l'attention au projet donc qui
permettent donc alors c'est si je
reprends le vocab de la loi
l'implanta des implants les
implantations industrielles pardon qui
valorise les ressources en ouvresbles
qui concourent aux transition
énergétique ou qui relève de
l'indépendance nationale donc on est OK
sur sur cette sur cette rédaction mais
il faudra trouver aussi une façon de
faire que c'est grands projets qui pour
certains sont certes d'envergure
régionale ou nationale bénéficie aussi
au territoire et il y a pas forcément de
raison que le territoire ou les
territoires concernés n'en prennent pas
une part aussi modeste soit elle et nous
ça renvoie la à la question de la
gouvernance que j'ai évoquais juste
avant
sur l'arrêt la part réservé donc c'est
l'article 8 de la pas réservé au
développement territorial on est
interrogatif sur cette sur cette sur
cette comment dire proposition mais
j'entends qu'elle répond à une elle veut
répondre en tout cas à une volonté de
souplesse et d'adaptation justement donc
je reviens pas sur ce que je dis tout à
l'heure sur les PLU intercommunaux de
notre point de vue c'est ce qui permet
le mieux de répondre à cette volonté
d'assouplir enfin d'adaptation enfin et
on y reviendra sûrement dans les
questions sur les outils c'est
indispensable c'est un enjeu fondamental
une partie peut être proposée par la loi
mais il y a d'autres sujets d'ailleurs
qui sont à traiter par la loi autour par
exemple des enjeux de zanes et fiscalité
mais le sénateur blanc a fait des
propositions dans un rapport et je crois
savoir que ce sera fera l'objet d'autres
travaux parlementaires à venir notamment
dans le cadre de la préparation de la
loi de finance pour l'année prochaine
beaucoup de choses n'auraient ne
relèvent pas de la loi pour autant donc
c'est tout ce qui relève de l'ingénierie
de la solidarité territoriale de la
capacité des territoires communes et ou
intercommunalités en tout cas le blog
local de porter des politiques d'habitat
d'agir sur l'habitat ancien pour être
attractif parce que face à l'absence de
foncif il faut aussi qu'on les outils
politiques et des moyens financiers et
techniques pour aller sur ces sur ce
nouveau modèle entre guillemets de
développement
en tout cas et je conclurai là-dessus la
loi climat résilience et l'enjeu d'usage
c'est fondamentalement ce qu'elles font
si là où historiquement c'était plutôt
une ressource entre guillemets infinie
où on se projetait dans une consommation
sans limite entre guillemets de notre
foncier on a décidé par la loi climat la
France a décidé par la loi Clément
résilience que ce foncier était devenu
une ressource finie et et entre
guillemets vite fini parce que même si
c'est les 30 prochaines années c'est
c'est demain entre guillemets en matière
de consommation foncière donc au delà
des des éléments législatifs c'est aussi
un changement de paradigme
parce que être propriétaire aujourd'hui
de foncier de gérer du foncier
d'ailleurs quel qu'on soit propriétaire
ou gestionnaire au sens large c'est
finalement gérer une part d'intérêt
général et puis une seule part d'intérêt
privé et c'est tout ça aussi qu'il faut
qui est interroger et qui doit faire
l'objet de pédagogie de l'ensemble des
acteurs et j'espère que le débat aussi
sur cette PPL le permettra
et donc l'ensemble des acteurs publics
notamment le blog local commune et
communauté et pour nous le mieux à même
de noter de mener cette politique en
dentelle entre guillemets mais on a
besoin comme j'ai dit de moyen de
juridiques techniques et financiers donc
sur le juridique une partie relève du
cadre législatif mais en restant le plus
simple possible et de laisser une vraie
part de souplesse à la liberté locale
donc une loi qui précise qui simplifie
mais qui n'est peut-être pas trop
justement trop précise pour qui pour
contraindre les projets locaux et la
diversité des réalités locales merci
monsieur gouttebelle monsieur Baker qui
souhaite prendre la parole monsieur
gouttebelle
pour commencer
et on fait un devoir très bien
donc on répondra aux questions à deux
voix tout à l'heure merci Madame
je fais en sorte que ça marche mieux
est-ce que c'est mieux madame le
Président
je vais parler plus aussi
tout d'abord merci effectivement pour
l'invitation
voilà
vous m'entendez mieux
est-ce que c'est mieux madame la
Présidente
est-ce que c'est bon pour vous si tout
le monde se tait
silencieux allez-y
merci de votre compréhension tout
d'abord effectivement
sur les objectifs à atteindre
alors on entend plus rien
vous m'entendez pas
je suis désolé
je ne bouge plus ce qu'il est important
derrière tout ça c'est effectivement
l'importance du rééquilibrage
territorial la prise en compte
effectivement des territoires qui ont pu
être vertueux dans ces 10 dernières
années ce qu'il est important est-ce que
l'on souhaite au travers de cette pppl
c'est qu'il y a une prise en compte
effectivement de la ruralité ce que vous
proposez au Sénat et avec dans notre
culture une interrogation entre le 1 ha
et ce que peut proposer l'Assemblée le
fameux 1% qui conduit à plutôt porter un
avantage pour le secteur
urbain dans tous ces éléments là madame
la Présidente on se doit quand même de
rappeler actuellement je crois que 30%
du territoire n'est pas couvert par un
Scott et 25% des communes rurales ne
sont seulement
réglementés que par le règlement
national d'urbanisme
qu'effectivement ça nous crée des
contraintes et quand j'entends et je le
comprends
mes collègues élus précédents qui
s'appuient effectivement sur les scottes
mais on a une partie des territoires
dont il faudra trouver un moyen et une
méthode pour qu'il puisse faire la
remonter de leur projet et je crois que
ce qui nous anime tous aujourd'hui
autour de la table est-ce que j'ai pu
entendre c'est un droit au projet un
droit à la vie j'ai entendu
effectivement parler des Adrets et s'il
y a des avantages fiscaux sur ce côté-là
c'est bien qu'il y a des fragilités et
il éclaire qu'il faut qu'elle puisse
continuer à se développer ces mêmes
territoires et on a on le sait tous
qu'on a tendance et que l'État a
tendance quand il y a des documents
d'urbanisme à rédaction à privilégier
les territoires en expansion en
augmentation de démographie et là aussi
ça serait une erreur de mettre un peu
les autres territoires sous cloche
pour justement en leur disant vous avez
perdu de la démographie
vous n'avez pas forcément besoin d'avoir
des grands projets dans le contexte dans
lequel on est de réindustrie déviation
de reprise de possession de sa
gouvernance de son sa capacité à
s'auto-alimenter et ainsi de suite il le
fera bien des espaces et je pense que
dans de nombreux territoires ruraux il y
aura de la place pour effectivement
refaire 10 de l'activité économique un
peu différente dans tous ces éléments
madame la Présidente effectivement les
mers ruraux vous remercient de laisser
plus de temps au temps parce que dans le
contexte actuel le temps imparti pour
l'estrade est avec toutes les
déclinaisons territoriales si on veut
aller vite il faut aussi prendre le
temps du dialogue et de l'écoute des
territoires et des enjeux des
territoires et c'est je reviens là
dessus sur cette différenciation
territoriale qui est importante ma
conclusion dans ce premier jet c'est que
derrière tout ça l'objectif de
diminution de 50% des consommations
on vous l'avez tous dit vous en avez
tous dit aussi la définition et la
nomenclature des grands projets d'État
qui l'État lui aussi devra être vertueux
parce que l'impact qu'il est nécessaire
de comptabiliser à part si sur un droit
sans les grands projets nationaux
européens constituent 25
l'effort qu'il y aura à faire dans tous
les territoires sera pas de 50% mais de
75% en moins par rapport à l'existant
tout de suite et je crois que cette
inquiétude est partagée par tout le
monde ça fait maintenant longtemps qu'on
attend cette définition là et il est
absolument nécessaire que cela puisse
sortir aussi pour qu'on ait des échanges
constructifs dans les territoires et
sans cette inconnue là c'est quand même
une inconnue à multiples facteurs qui va
nous pénaliser dans nos futurs
interactions avec les régions et les
documents qui peuvent être
supracommunaux donc derrière tout ça
madame la Présidente
l'association des méruraux vous refera
passer puisque le questionnaire vous
avez pu vous envoyer dans un premier
temps et qui va se poursuivre avec du
questionnement on vous refera passer
nous aussi tous nos écrits qui pourront
venir alimenter vos travaux et vos
débats au Sénat je ne serai pas plus
loin que ça madame la Présidente dans un
premier temps mais merci à tous merci
beaucoup monsieur gouttebelle monsieur
Decker
non pour l'instant
à ce stade je n'interviendrai pas plus
nous sommes deux élus de la MR Goudel et
moi-même à travailler sur ce sujet
depuis tout le temps on va pas se
répéter à chaque fois dans nos discours
donc je vais laisser monsieur goodbel
s'exprimer au nom de la MRS puisqu'il
est aussi vice-président national voilà
j'interviendrai en cas de
complément voilà c'est très gentil merci
beaucoup
plus attendre je sais de la parole à
Monsieur le rapporteur pour quelques
séries de questions merci Madame à la
présidente chère Valérie et chers
collègues et Mesdames et Messieurs les
représentants des élus locaux
effectivement nous avons des questions à
vous poser et je procéderai en deux
temps donc deux séries de questions la
première série de questions concerne
l'article premier en tant que logique
qui repousse d'un an l'entrée en vigueur
des différents documents de
planification d'urbanisme élaborés au
niveau régional et local afin de leur
laisser le temps d'intégrer les
trajectoires de réduction
d'artificialisation définie au niveau
supérieur est-ce que vous seriez
favorable à ce que pour gagner encore un
peu de temps l'on réduisent le délai des
modifications des scottes et des PLU en
répliquant la mesure qui permet aux sera
d'être de procéder à la consultation
simultanée du public et des personnes
publiques associées
d'autre part c'est un lien avec
l'article 12 de la proposition de loi
qui prévoit un sourcier est statué et un
droit de préemption zan comment donner
aux élus les outils pour réussir à
maîtriser dès maintenant leur
consommation d'espace alors avoir même
pardon que les documents d'urbanisme
soient modifiés en effet les compteurs
zanes tournent déjà depuis août 2021
élément important que tous les élus
n'ont sans doute pas encore bien
identifiés concernant l'article 2 et les
rapports entre le stradet et le document
d'urbanisme locaux avez-vous des
informations sur l'état d'instruction du
recours logé par l'AMF contre les
décrets d'application de la loi qui ont
rendu obligatoire le recours à des
règles du fascicule plus contraignantes
région de France nous a indiqué lors de
son audition que les régions n'étaient
pas forcément demandeuses de ce rôle
privilégions des solutions à la carte
l'article 3 instaure une conférence
régionale du gouvernance du zan qui
aurait vocation à remplacer les
conférences des scottes en y renforçant
la représentation des élus lorsque nous
avons interrogé à ce sujet les régions
nous ont indiqué que l'élaboration des
stradettes faisaient l'objet de
concertation approfondie avec les élus
locaux notamment concernant les
objectifs d'artificialisation des sols
et leur territorialisation
confirmez-vous cette affirmation
l'échelon communal en particulier est-il
assez entendu par la région selon vous
nous avons notre conçu notre proposition
de conférence régionale comme lieu de
dialogue renforcé pour une mise en
oeuvre d'usine plus apaisée mais ça ne
fait pas consensus on le voit bien
encore cet après-midi quelle est la
position des élus que vous êtes et que
représentés à ce sujet concernant les
articles 4 et 5 qui traitent des projets
d'ampleur national qui pourraient être
exclus de la comptabilité des
collectivités territoriales mais aussi
des projets d'ampleur régional
mutualisés les dispositifs et les
procédures proposées vous paraissent-ils
pertinents comment ces projets doivent
être doit-il être identifié selon vous
et si j'osais comment vous voyez le
décompte de ces projets nationaux
éventuellement article 6 nous aimerions
connaître votre position sur la
proposition d'appliquer au stade les
critères de territorialisation déjà
prévu par la loi pour les Scotts
êtes-vous favorable à ce que soit pris
en compte au niveau régional c'est même
critères de répartition de l'effort
notamment les enjeux de ruralité
l'impact des protections du littoral et
de la montagne les enjeux de mutation
économiques et autres
nous cédons la parole pour répondre à
chacun cette première série de questions
merci
merci monsieur
comme ça a été le cas dans le même ordre
que le propoliminaire ou comment
souhaitez-vous
monsieur décor va commencer
monsieur débat pardon il est là
quelqu'un
va s'exprimer au nom de l'AMF mais par
contre si vous pouviez nous
pouvez-vous vous présenter à ce moment
là madame
alors
Nathalie fourneau oui je suis désolé
je sais pas m'exprimer au pied levé je
m'en excuse peut-être vos questions
posaient-elles sur tout sur le
contentieux devant le Conseil d'État
c'est ça
tout à fait en tout cas il y avait
celle-là d'autres aussi mais en tout cas
il y avait celle-là oui
alors sur le recours donc devant le
Conseil d'État sachez que l'instruction
est en cours en cours avec un échange de
mémoire et une réplique et selon les
avocats qui suivent ce sujet
voilà on attend effectivement la clôture
de l'instruction si effectivement le
Conseil ça considère que le
contradictoire est achevé et avec
peut-être
en tout cas dans les délais actuels une
décision autour du printemps enfin voilà
dans l'année qui s'écoule voilà sur la
dans l'année entre le moment de la
saisine pardon et le et
la décision du Conseil d'État dessert au
maximum au mois de juin c'est un peu ce
qu'on nous a dit voilà sur le
contentieux du Conseil d'État donc entre
les deux décrets l'un sur la
nomenclature qui est en cours de
réécriture ce que vous savez déjà
puisque vous avez auditionné le
ministère et notamment la DHP le décret
est en train d'être écrit notamment avec
les échelles et la catégorie 5 et
ensuite le décret sera d'aide qui a
aussi l'effet d'objet d'un recours
notamment sur la question la fixation de
la territorisation systématique dans les
règles du fascicule plutôt que dans les
objectifs comme l'Inde qui la loi et sur
le degré de précision qui induit la
définition des projets d'intérêt
régionaux et nationaux dans le décret
notamment et sur la prise en compte des
efforts passés c'était un point aussi
essentiel du recours
madame parce qu'on a du mal à comprendre
ce que vous dites
plus lentement
je suis désolé est-ce que vous m'avez
entendu je suis pas dans un endroit on
vous entend très loin aussi pour tout
vous dire d'accord est-ce que vous
m'entendez vous vous m'entendez mieux
ça va et surtout si parler peut-être
plus lentement comme ça
d'accord je vais couper la caméra si ça
te dérange pas peut-être que vous
m'entendez mieux comme ça
est-ce que vous m'entendez
oui on vous entend mais allez-y
est-ce que vous m'avez entendu sur le
contentieux sur le recours
allez-y continuez on va essayer de ne
pas se parler et puis
alors sur la conférence de gouvernance
en fait l'AMF avait une position mais
que vous connaissez peut-être déjà tout
ce qu'elles étaient dans les 20
propositions que la émette vous avez
transmise qui était plutôt de de
proroger entre guillemets le rôle des
conférences de Scott actuel élargi à des
collèges de discussion un peu plus un
peu plus donc
étendu aux communes et aux
intercommunalités des virus de discuter
sur la trajectoire zan dans le au niveau
si vous voulez de l'interscott avec
aussi un rôle renforcé des commissions
de conciliation des documents
d'urbanisme qui sont aujourd'hui
fermés à la saisine des communes des
intercommunalités qui portent pourtant
les documents d'urbanisme pour justement
permettre un dialogue
entre le préfet et les différents
porteurs et acteurs de l'élaboration des
documents d'urbanisme pour affiner les
trajectoires zanes au niveau
départemental va sous l'autorité du
préfet et en lien avec les collectivités
porteuses des documents d'urbanisme donc
avec un double rôle conférence des
scottes donc élargie dans leur groupe de
travail et ensuite un groupe voilà au
niveau entre guillemets départementales
dans le cadre renforcé des commissions
de conciliation document d'urbanisme
existantes ça c'est la position de la NF
ensuite autre question c'était donc sur
pardon je
sur les autres questions
sur les raccourcir les étapes de
procédure pour les stradettes comme pour
les scottes cela nous semble
effectivement indispensables dès lors
qu'il y a des délais qui sont
incompressibles c'est ce que nous ont
finalement fait valoir les élus c'est de
dire si effectivement il y a un décalage
dans l'adoption des stradettes on se
décalage va se faire ressentir de fait
sur les procédures pour adopter les
scottes et les PLU d'où l'intérêt des
outils que vous avez proposé des sursis
à statuer et refus de permis de
construire et autres droits de promotion
pour réserve foncière pour justement
permettre de gérer la transition sur sur
les projets qui porteraient atteinte en
fait à la à la trajectoire en cours de
définition sur l'objectif âme
ensuite sur la décompte des grands
projets la position de l'AMF c'est
effectivement idéalement de sortir ce
très grands projets du décompte du zan
pour éviter qu'il
que le rend prise
impacte trop fortement les hectares déjà
finalement alloué aux différents régions
on voit bien qu'ici il y a voilà deux
positions qui s'opposent entre celle du
gouvernement celle du Sénat et
potentiellement le souhait des élus de
voir sortir ses grands projets donc
effectivement c'est d'être pour la
sortie du compte mais une mutualisation
ou pas de mutualisation
alors c'est nous notre position c'est de
pas de mutualisation mais effectivement
on voit bien que là il va y avoir un
enjeu au niveau de de cette sortie là
mais tout dépend ce que disent les élus
de la quantité si on veut rester
cohérent avec l'objectif âme de la
quantité entre guillemets de grands
projets qui doivent sortir c'est
effectivement c'est une trop grande
liste ce sera pas compris qu'elle soit à
ce point d'interrogation à l'objectif
zan si c'est une liste plus réduite on
peut considérer qu'effectivement elle
peut sortir si je peux me permettre
pour bien comprendre comme Monsieur
debas s'est exprimé avant vous il
m'avait semblé que Monsieur débat disait
qu'il faudrait qu'il y ait une remontée
mais une mutualisation ensuite si j'ai
bien compris une péréquation c'est à
dire une mutualisation enfin moi
j'entends ça
est-ce que là dessus il y a une position
MF où il y a encore des échanges
là-dessus c'est pas stabilisé
alors la position à MF était la suivante
c'était effectivement la sortie des
grands projets c'est celle qu'on vous a
communiqué la sortie des grands projets
sans mutualisation en revanche
effectivement au regard on regarde des
discussions actuelles qu'on ne peut
ignorer et notamment de
cet immeubles de la de l'absence de
volonté de finalement de sortir les
grands projets qu'on a compris
si on doit effectivement considérer
qu'on doit mutualiser les grands projets
il faut que ce cette mutualisation ne se
soit pas trop importante voilà
c'est un peu la question qui est voilà
qui est en cours de réflexion chez nous
en tout cas très sincèrement en tout ce
qui serait utile pour nous c'est si vous
pouviez nous formuler une proposition
assez plus précise en tout cas sur les
contours c'est à dire qu'est-ce qui doit
remonter qu'est-ce qui doit redescendre
en tout cas qu'est-ce qu'il doit faire
l'objet d'une péréquation d'une
mutualisation d'une redescente en fait
dans les comptes fonciers des régions si
on s'entend bien ce serait utile pour
nous de comprendre les deux niveaux pour
pouvoir appréhender au mieux la position
des effets de l'Association des maires
tout à fait je suis très bien mais
écoutez on vous enverra merci beaucoup
c'est très gentil monsieur le rapporteur
va préciser peut-être sa question merci
madame la Présidente pardon de d'être
insistant et lourd sur le sujet mais
mais c'est un sujet qui crucial pour
nous la Commission spéciale sur le sujet
du zan voilà et alors pensez-vous notre
interlocutrice après midi donc pardon
pour la flèche mais je suis désolé il y
en a pas un qui nous raconte la même
chose au niveau de l'AMF c'est à dire
sortie d'enveloppe ou pas et puis quel
type de décompte est-ce que c'est une
sortie d'enveloppe totale ou est-ce
qu'on répartit de nouveau via une
péréquation voilà et ce qui ne facilite
pas les travaux de la commission
notamment quand on discute avec le
ministre sur le sujet vous voyez
puis qu'effectivement
ont chacun dit la MF pense que oui
alors
ça serait bien de nous envoyer de nous
éclairer définitivement et
officiellement je pense que Madame
fourneau veut préciser
la position de la MF est très claire
c'est celle qui a été publiée pendant
les 20 propositions où il était question
d'une sortie et c'est la position du
Sénat donc là dessus on n'a jamais été
ambiguë c'était vraiment la vôtre en
fait c'est la sortie des grands projets
après là on voit bien qu'il y a un
principe de réalité des discussions
aujourd'hui qui est de savoir si on
perait pas si vous voulez le la position
de repli c'est de dire s'il faut opérer
quoi il faut savoir de quoi on parle et
de voilà simplement et effectivement que
cette péréquation soit pas soit soit
tout à fait transparent je crois que
c'est ce qu'a dit Jean-François dedans
en fait maintenant la position
officielle de la MF c'est la sortie des
grands projets très bien non non mais
c'est juste ça la précision qu'on
voulait madame fourneau on a bien
compris qu'en fait vous êtes en train de
cheminer et d'essayer de comprendre et
d'anticiper des choses que vous
ressentez des échanges que vous avez eu
avec le gouvernement pour être clair
mais que votre souci votre souhait
c'était de ne pas impacter les
enveloppes régionales au départ en tout
cas de trouver effectivement cette
solution au travers de la sortie donc
effectivement on serait très heureux
d'avoir tout l'état de vos réflexions en
tout cas sur cette question merci merci
[Musique]
pour rebondir sur cette question des
grands projets interco de France on n'a
pas de position arrêté là-dessus mais je
trouve que c'est dommage mais je
pourquoi on en a pas aussi et l'échange
qu'on vient d'avoir les deux de mon
point de vue l'éclair aussi c'est
qu'au-delà de la discussion théorique un
grand projet on va national on va le
mettre là un grand projet régional on va
le faire on va le mettre là et Françoise
Rossignol me contredire assise une
bêtise mais dans nos conférences
régionales de Scott concrètement quand
on recommence à se dire au-delà de la
théorie d'un projet d'enveloppe régional
ou d'un planeur local c'est qu'est-ce
qu'on met derrière et donc typiquement
une liaison routière dans quelle mesure
elle est d'ampleur parfois un itinéraire
national européen mais qui va aussi
faire de la du développement régional
voir local et donc se dire un grand
projet est forcément dans une seule et
même catégorie
c'est c'est sur le papier ça marche
peut-être dans la vraie vie ça marche
difficilement donc ça renvoie la
question de la gouvernance et qu'à un
moment on arrive à qualifier les projets
mais c'est de la dentelle et malgré
toute votre bonne volonté ou vous vous
Sénat nous le Parlement la nation ne
pourra pas dans un document législatif
définir clairement tel c'est un projet
national ça va là et on en fait tel
traitement parce qu'il y a une telle
diversité derrière un projet ça veut
dire tout est plein de choses une LGV ça
dessert peu local mais une route il y a
toujours des échangeurs des ronds-points
un moment qui font que ça ça vient
irriguer le irriguer le territoire de de
très près et c'est toute la difficulté
du sujet et donc se dire que une
nationale par exemple et serait décompté
dans un enveloppe national et il ne
viendrait pas du tout impacter le local
de la même façon qu'une LG vous qu'un
canal
je pense que c'est ça ne durable enfin
dans le temps à l'épreuve de les défaits
de la pratique sur le local ça ne
marchera pas parce qu'on se dira mais
attendez pourquoi autant le je connais
pas je suis pas un spécialiste ni
ingénieur en canal ou je sais pas quoi
mais un canal j'imagine que on crée pas
tout des infrastructures tous les
kilomètres une LGV c'est peut-être un
peu plus proche et puis une route ça
n'est encore plus et donc un grand
projet ça veut tout et rien dire et là
je parle de de
tout type de dessert de mobilité mais
sur d'autres outils une centrale
nucléaire j'imagine qu'autour de la
centrale nucléaire il y a aussi toutes
des sous-traitants qui font du
développement local qui vont peut-être
aller jusqu'à l'artisan et donc derrière
le grand projet de centrale nucléaire il
y a aussi toute une du tissu de
développement économique local et donc
comment on qualifie comment se répartit
et c'est pour ça qu'à interco de France
on évoquait sur les grands projets qu'on
n'imagine pas que ça puisse être tout
blanc ou tout noir et que il faut il
faudrait pouvoir qualifier ça renvoie la
question de la gouvernance qualifier
dans chaque projet au moment une
certaine de quote-part peut-être
régionale voir c'est beaucoup plus
compliqué j'ai bien conscience que je ne
simplifie pas le débat mais c'est la
peut-être
telle que nous l'avons rédigé sur la
gouvernance
faites appel à la gouvernance et sur la
description en fait sur la façon de
définir les grands projets d'intérêt
national européen avec une définition
d'une part et une inscription dans le
document du sera d'être quelle remarque
par rapport à ça comment quelle
préconisations vous feriez sur la
gouvernance d'évoquer
quel est le niveau de satisfaction sur
ces articles comment vous les voyez sur
la composition de la conférence
régionale du gouvernance du zan ce que
je disais tout à l'heure dans mon propos
introductif c'est que la composition
telle qu'elle est proposée donc de dire
il y a tant de représentant de la région
donc 15 représentants de la région 5ds
10 des EPCI compétents en matière d'urbo
- 5 non couverts par un Scott je
m'arrête là dans l'énumération mais en
Bretagne par exemple il y a des scottes
partout donc dire qu'il faut 5
représentants d'établissements mon
couvert par un Scott ça marche pas
des communes non couvertes un document
d'urbanisme ce qui est vrai en Bretagne
n'est pas vrai en haut de France n'est
pas vrai en Auvergne Rhône-Alpes ou
DOM-TOM donc la composition avec
telle et tel nombre de de de
représentants de chaque catégorie entre
guillemets ça ne peut pas marcher
partout en France donc je suggérais
telle heure dans mon propos introductif
de laisser à chaque région dans le cadre
de dialogue avec les différents
représentants les conférences des
scottes ont déjà une une expérience en
la matière de se dire c'est quoi la
bonne gouvernance c'est quoi la
composition d'une instance de
gouvernance je suggérais j'ai entendu le
brouha de la salle qui semblait me dire
que je ma proposition faisait réagir et
je pense plutôt négativement mais les
ctape existent je sais que ça ne marche
pas partout je suis pas naïf et on
prêche pas la ctape pour la CTP partout
mais là c'était elle mais elle a le
mérite délire des représentants par
catégorie de la commune à la région en
passant par l'interco et le département
donc un moment il y aura quand même une
question de légitimité et plus on
donnera de pouvoir à cette conférence
régionale de gouvernance plus ça
légitimité sera questionnée donc
je réagissais madame la Présidente juste
à une remarque et je veux rebondir sur
ce qu'il y a est-ce qu'il vient d'être
dit nous avons tous une expérience et on
sait tous que y compris au niveau
départemental lorsqu'on a la compétence
en matière de voir il est départementale
on nous allait pour faire un giratoire
pour des raisons de sécurité et 2 ans
après on aperçoit la petite zone
d'activité qui qui naît et qui vient se
brancher sur le giratoire on l'a tous
connu donc
ce que vous venez de dire me parle par
rapport à la légitimité moi je pense que
la conférence territoriale de l'action
publique j'entends bien quelle marche
différemment selon les endroits et si on
veut que ça ne reste pas une chambre
d'enregistrement chers collègues je
pense qu'il faut que la loi lui donne
des rendez-vous périodiques avec du
contenu et le contenu le sujet dont on
parle n'apparaît être un contenu tout à
fait intéressant pour être inscrit à
l'ordre du jour de la CP ap
merci chers collègues monsieur Miossec
peut-être pour terminer votre propos et
en ramasser puisque je voudrais qu'on
puisse entendre aussi madame la madame
la vice-présidente et Monsieur Gouttebel
ou monsieur Baker je ne sais pas si
Monsieur décor était là j'ai déjà évoqué
un certain nombre de choses tout à
l'heure donc sur les délaissés sur la
proposition de de de superposer entre
guillemets certains délais pour gagner
du temps mais notre position c'est de ne
pas reculer l'échéance finale c'est
gagner du temps dans la dans la période
de consultation et de travail mais pour
gagner du temps en dialogue mais ne pas
reculer la date finale parce que on
plaide le fait qu'il ne faut pas de faut
pas comment dire retarder trop le moment
où on aura une donnée enfin un cadre
stabilisé et puis sur les outils j'irai
pas plus loin du coup mais sur les
outils là aussi c'est une très bonne
nouvelle que celle qui est proposée dans
la loi on a besoin de l'outil pour
pouvoir présenter pour pouvoir agir sur
l'habitat ancien c'est indispensable
parce que le marché lui le marché de
l'immobilier du foncier n'a pas attendu
nos débats d'aujourd'hui pour pour
prendre en compte le zan et la et la
nouvelle donne sur le foncier
merci
[Musique]
je lui ai répondu un certain nombre de
questions par rapport au grand projet
pour nous ils doivent être sortis dans
une enveloppe gérée par l'État
à lui de s'appliquer des 50% en
rénaturant
mais c'est une sortie et chaque niveau
de collectivité doit s'appliquer la
règle à lui-même c'était le on a
longuement discuté énormément dans la
diversité de nos territoires il nous a
semblé que c'était ce qui
était à la fois le plus équitable et
permettait
d'avoir une dynamique et que l'État ne
se sorte pas de l'esprit de la loi
puisqu'effectivement nous partageons
l'esprit de la loi quant à la
gouvernance pardon parce que c'est un
point très important la vice-présidente
alors c'est une position qui est
régulièrement
reprise ici je dis pas qu'elle sera la
position finale néanmoins quand on
évoque ça avec le gouvernement
on nous explique que finalement il n'y a
pas tant d'État que ça que le foncier
n'appartient pas à l'état que l'État
n'apparaît nulle part que certes on a
une impression d'intérêt je fais
l'avocat du diable voilà mais que donc
rêver ou espérer avoir un décompte
et que ça intéresse un compte national
parce que l'État pourrait s'appliquer à
lui-même ce qui cherche à appliquer aux
autres c'est une fantaisie voilà ce
qu'on nous répond vous répondez quoi à
ça éventuellement
jusqu'à présent ne nous avait pas dit
que c'était une fantaisie mais
je l'entends si ce n'est que de toute
manière il faut bien il les définir ses
grands projets
qu'il soit que la question soit de
mutualisation une enveloppe de l'état de
toute manière il faut les définir il
faut définir l'enveloppe et donc il nous
a semblé que
que l'État s'applique à lui-même et
laisse finalement les régions sur
l'enveloppe qui était prévu par la loi
semble être pour nous la meilleure
solution
par rapport à la gouvernance pour aller
assez rapidement moi je vais rappeler
que 97% de la population et 86% des
communes font partie d'un Scott et que
donc la place des scottes dans les 7
gouvernance doit être important
primordial 5 pour dans certaines régions
ou effectivement il n'y a quasiment pas
de commune qui ne sont pas couvertes par
un Scott parait je dirais peut-être un
peu fantaisiste à certains moments
c'est-à-dire en tout cas ne paraît pas
réaliste et que la répartition de
l'effort dans la connaissance de la
des diversités de nos territoires c'est
bien au niveau des scottes qu'elle peut
être mise en oeuvre alors quand derrière
le scotch il y a un pays on facilite
encore les choses mais que et que c'est
l'esprit global de la loi puisque
finalement tout le territoire devrait
être couvert par biscotte et que donc la
loi devrait renfor CER encore le rôle
des scottes et que c'est la logique même
de nos documents d'urbanisme
merci Madame Rossignol monsieur goutte
le sursis est statué nous on propose
qu'il soit prolongé sur une durée de 4
ans de manière à nous permettre de
travailler et de d'établir des
stratégies positives alors effectivement
c'est toute la question aussi du modèle
économique sur lequel il faut travailler
et sur lequel on est qu'au début du
travail mais
laissez le temps de créer des dynamiques
et de nouveaux modèles de développement
dans le cadre du Zen très bien monsieur
gouttebelle et où Monsieur Decker je ne
sais pas et ensuite on passe aux
questions des collègues
je vais attaquer moi aussi dans des
zones puisque les questions voilà on
débordés sur la gouvernance
effectivement pour avoir la chance de
faire partir de la CPAP pour reprendre
par exemple
dans ma région elle s'est peu réunie et
pas depuis longtemps et là aussi si on
doit s'appuyer sur des choses qui
existent il faut mettre des
conditionnalités des règles du jeu qui
fassent que les élus qui puissent siéger
dans ces instances soit invités et et
soit consulter de la même façon vous
proposer effectivement le gouvernance du
zan
cette méthode effectivement peut nous
plaire dans le sens où ça ouvre ça peut
ouvrir localement à des discussions
objectives sur la représentation de tous
les territoires et effectivement on a
peut-être pas tous les mêmes chiffres
sur soit ou passeport moi j'en étais à
30% du territoire national non couvert
mais je peux me tromper aussi il faut
bien qu'on pense à ces territoires qui
sont pas couverts par des spots et
tout à l'heure au nom des mers ruraux
effectivement une inquiétude certaine
puisque tout de suite la grande la
nomenclature ne sort pas je l'ai dit
tout à l'heure
nous étions et nous sommes favorables à
ce qu'ils puissent y avoir une
mutualisation une péridation c'est à
dire que l'endroit où ont lieu les
travaux d'infrastructure ne soit pas
forcément que porter cet effort par
cette région là ça nous semble essentiel
mais il semble essentiel je le redis que
l'État aussi s'applique à lui-même
malgré ce que j'ai pu entendre tout à
l'heure
sur le fait que ce soit un peu illusoire
comme méthode il n'empêche qu'il faut
bien que les forces soient partagées
dans un futur proche si on veut tenir
l'enjeu qu'il va nous arriver donc nous
on était effectivement d'accord sur
cette partie là sur la superposition des
délais on pourrait dire que pourquoi pas
effectivement parce que dans les
enchaînements cascades derrière
c'est quand même des années qu'il faut
avec un petit point d'attention aussi
la revoyure de tous les documents
d'urbanisme mon nécessité de nombreux
bureaux d'études et des coûts financiers
assez importants et reparler des coûts
financiers il me semble aussi l'occasion
tout de suite de repenter du doigt le
fait que ce sont les territoires qui
vont avoir à supporter financièrement
la revoyure de nombre de documents sur
cette partie là et sur les outils
effectivement qui seront donnés il faut
l'absolu nécessité d'outils donnés au
territoire où il puisse être plus
efficace pour présenter et garder entre
guillemets la légitimité de son destin
on parlait tout à l'heure du droit au
projet et pour le droit au projet il
faut pouvoir se projeter et justement
avoir l'aide des outils donc je ne sais
pas monsieur le rapporteur si j'ai
oublié des réponses au nom des mers
ruraux dans la multitude des questions
mais précisément et j'essaierai de
compléter
je propose la Jean-Baptiste de de
préciser les points qui le souhaitent
affiner sur l'article 8 et le 9 et de de
d'enchaîner sur quelques questions de
ceux qui voudraient compléter je sais
que Cécile que Carmen voulait poser une
question
Jean-Marc Boyer aussi et Jean Raymond
donc on va essayer de faire une salle
mais en reprenant d'abord les deux
articles 8 et 9 à préciser
merci même la présidente la deuxième
série de questions sera plus rapide que
pensez-vous de la proposition portée par
un article 7 de garantir en live évoqué
mais très con leur réévoque et je
regrette d'ailleurs que le maire de
Bourg-en-Bresse soit plus parmi nous
bref de garantir à chaque commune une
enveloppe minimale de un hectare sur 10
ans
et d'ailleurs vous faire réagir les
autres les unes et les autres sur la
contre proposition du Gouvernement sur
le droit à 1% de l'enveloppe urbanisé si
vous avez des choses à nous dire aussi
nous sommes très preneurs en tout cas la
PPL c'est le l'enveloppe minimal de un
hectare sur 10 ans nous l'avons conçu
comme une garantie et pas comme un droit
absolu artificialisé selon nos chiffres
cela permettra à 15000 communes en
quasi-totalité très peu dense peu dense
ou très peu dense d'avoir une petite
marge manœuvre ça représenterait au
total environ 8% de l'enveloppe
nationale d'artificialisation autorisée
ce qui est à peu près cohérent avec les
5 à 6% qu'on peser ces 15000 communes
dans l'artificialisation totale sur la
période de 10 ans passée dans le même
ordre d'idées que pensez-vous de la
proposition portée par l'article 8
visant à mettre en réserve au niveau de
chaque scotch une petite enveloppe qui
pourrait permettre de réaliser des
projets dans des petites communes
rurales qui n'auraient pas d'enveloppe
suffisantes un tel mécanisme de
solidarité territoriale et de précaution
pour éviter de porter préjudice au
projet d'intérêt territorial est-ce que
tout cela est pertinent selon vous à
l'article 9 nous aimerions connaître
votre appréciation sur le fait de
considérer les parcs et les jardins
comme des surfaces non artificialisées
sur la possibilité pour les EPCI et les
communes de délimiter des périmètres de
densification et de recyclage fonciers
au syndical l'artificialisation de ces
parcs les jardins ne serait pas
décompter est-ce que cela offre
davantage de flexibilité que la
nomenclature publiée par décret comme ça
en est l'intention selon vous ou pas et
on pourra dire un mot sur l'actualité du
nouveau décret comment nomenclature si
vous en avez la possibilité et enfin
l'article 10 nous aimerions recueillir
votre sentiment à propos des
dispositions prévues en faveur des
communes littorales sous musoraux sont
mises au recul du trait de côte et la
prise en compte des spécificités des
communes de montagne dans la
territorialisation du zan
merci merci Monsieur laporteur Cécile
cukerman oui merci peut-être que les
différences d'appréciation qui ont pu
être exprimées à travers cette table
ronde démontre aussi une loi finale au
départ en tout cas mal penser pour être
bien appliqué et qui laisse
effectivement beaucoup d'interprétations
à partir de là je crois qu'on a le choix
soit effectivement de dire on en reste
là et puis dans chaque territoire on
verra bien soit de se dire on prend le
débat nationalement et on garantit
effectivement et c'est pour ça que je
voulais revenir à un droit à construire
pour pour chaque chaque commune avec
très certainement des visions
différentes en tout cas ce qui a été
exprimé c'est effectivement est-ce que
l'on commence par aménager le territoire
à partir de l'échelon communale où
est-ce qu'on commence par la ménager à
partir d'autres échelons qui ont été
confortés au cours des dernières
décennies et la question n'est pas de
revenir dessus et ils ont quand même
compris voilà dans les différentes
interventions des différences d'approche
sur cette vision là on va pas sur le
droit à construire et compris puisque
Jean-François debat a pris a pris
l'exemple au nom de la MF
comment est-ce qu'à un moment donné on
réfléchit et peut-être pour aller encore
un peu plus même que dans ce qui est
écrit dans la proposition de loi que
nous avons déposé cette capacité à
pouvoir mutualiser parce que moi
j'entends bien évidemment pour des
communes
de la taille d'une préfecture telle que
Paulette Bourg-en-Bresse un hectare
c'est pas grand chose mais pour autant
pour une commune de 80 habitants c'est
beaucoup
en revanche pour une commune de type
préfecture je reprends cet exemple là
mais je pourrais je vais changer je vais
prendre celui de Saint-Étienne comme ça
il y aura pas de deux sujets des friches
a requalifier elles se comptent avec
plusieurs hectares je pourrais même
zoomer un peu plus dans mon département
j'ai changé avec le maire de Montbrison
on est déjà à 5 6 hectares en capacité
de de les requalifier et donc de gagner
est-ce qu'à un moment donné ça on le met
dans le débat à l'échelle d'un
territoire qui est pas forcément un pays
qui est pas forcément une
intercommunalité qui peut d'ailleurs
être un territoire plus petit pour se
dire que mais oui on a des centralités
qui elles vont requalifier pour
renensifier et que ça ça donne entre
guillemets de de l'air un peu de de
respiration possible pour les communes
et ainsi on recrée de la coopération
communale intercommunale plus que même
si je sais que tout se passe très bien
dans tous les territoires certainement
je suis quelqu'un d'exception on sait
aussi quand même que dans les
intercommunalités dans les pluies et
dans les scottes il y a quand même
parfois quelques débats quelques
tensions et en tout cas quelques
difficultés à ce que chaque commune y
trouve vraiment sa place
si Cécile la parole à Jean-Marc Boyer
oui merci madame la Présidente
ce que on a entendu aujourd'hui des
différents témoignages c'est correspond
à déjà ce qu'on a entendu depuis
plusieurs mois en particulier concernant
la conférence des scottes et les
représentations qu'il y a au niveau des
grandes régions
moi j'ai entendu la loi doit renforcer
le rôle des scottes c'est ce que vous
avez dit je crois madame la
vice-présidente
et bien moi j'ai envie de vous dire que
la loi va renforcé le rôle des communes
et des petites communes rurales et de
montagne
parce qu'aujourd'hui dans ce qu'on
entend on est dans une démarche
descendante du stradette au Scott à la
comcom aux communes et
quand est-ce qu'on aura une démarche
ascendante qui part des besoins de la
commune et des petites communes rurales
ouards des communes de montagne pour
aller effectivement vers une démarche
qui sera construit construite avec les
pluies etc etc je crois que il faut
qu'on change absolument la manière de
réfléchir bon il me semble que
aujourd'hui la garantie rurale de quand
on dit un hectare cette garantie rurale
elle est essentielle si on ne garde pas
cette garantie rurale
je veux dire on va vers une une démarche
où on aura des grandes orientations qui
seront prises au niveau de conférence
d'organisation ou les les maires et on
le voit déjà au niveau des intercours on
a des mers qui ne vont pratiquement plus
en réunion d'intercaux des maires de
petites communes on le sait tous et si
on continue comme ça on va complètement
déshabiller encore le rôle du maire il
me semble que c'est encore le maire qui
donne le permis de attribute qui signe
permet de construire enfin je crois si
demain c'est
l'intercommunalité ou si c'est le Scott
ou autre je pense pas que je pense pas
que ce soit une bonne chose donc pour
moi le maire doit garder l'initiative du
développement de sa commune il doit
garder le droit au projet parce que lui
aussi l'endroit au projet comme ne pas
avoir le droit au projet les les projets
nationaux les projets régionaux etc donc
ce grand projet doit être et doit être
conservé et mon dernier point parce que
je suis quand même extrêmement déçu de
la position de l'AMF m'attendez quand
même à autre chose quelque chose de
beaucoup plus clair et moi je propose
une seule chose c'est qu'on est le
président de l'AMFA personne qui
viennent en audition ici qui nous donne
la position claire et nette de l'AMF par
rapport à cette proposition de loi on
peut pas avoir des positions comme
aujourd'hui on a eu moi je suis
incapable de vous dire ce qui ressort de
la position de la MF aujourd'hui c'est
pas normal
merci
Jean-Marc Jean Raymond Hugonnet
merci madame la Présidente je serai
court je ne vous cache pas que j'ai un
certain malaise depuis le début de cette
audition sans être redondant mais quand
même appuyé ce que vient de dire
Jean-Marc Boyer avec pertinence je
trouve totalement baroque que pour une
audition de cette importance l'AMF ne
soit pas présente
je trouve ça totalement baroque
maintenant
encore une fois qu'on ne se méprenne pas
sur mon propos
l'intercommunalité nous vivons avec
j'entends monsieur que tout à l'heure
avec des trémolos dans la voie presque
nous parlait des pays lui
et si nous sommes en région
Île-de-France ce monsieur le pays n'a
pas grande
ce que je veux dire il a pas eu un grand
succès pour autant moi je veux mettre en
parallèle deux choses ça a été dit tout
à l'heure c'est l'article 72 de notre
constitution même si un vent de réforme
des institutions souffle sur nos têtes
l'article 72 éclairs aucune collectivité
territoriale ne peut exercer une tutelle
sur une autre page 24
maintenant une chose est claire la
commune est une collectivité de plein
exercice elle ne pourra jamais jamais
être mise à l'écart sur la base de
comité Théodule qui se réunissent de
conférence de ceci d'institutions de
cela si nous by passons les communes
c'est le socle de notre République
qui est clairement en jeu alors
excusez-moi de le dire avec un peu avec
passion mais j'oublie pas qu'ici c'est
notre mission c'est même l'article 24 de
la Constitution qui le fixe nous
représentons les territoires nous
représentons les communes
j'entends et avec d'autres nombreux
qu'on les respecte qu'elles soient
rurales de montagne de région parisienne
mais il y a un moment donné où on peut
réfléchir mais à force de de créer des
structures qui viennent s'entasser dont
on ne comprend plus la gouvernance et
dont on ne maîtrise plus la gouvernance
c'est l'avenir de notre pays dont il
dépend donc je voulais le dire avec
force merci chers collègues la parole à
Angèle Préville puis Sonia de la
pauvreté merci madame la Présidente donc
moi j'avais d'abord une première
question est-ce que la PPL doit définir
une doit donner une définition de la
renaturation est-ce que voilà et si vous
en avez une à nous proposer moi j'en ai
plus ou moins une mais bon voilà je
voilà je suis à votre écoute et après
sur la ce qui est en train de se passer
sur notre territoire c'est-à-dire la
mise en place dans toutes mes intercos
dans le lot de du pluie avec des mers
qui subissent un petit peu des mers
ruraux bien sûr qui subissent des choses
épouvantables à savoir que le bureau
d'études établi par photo aérienne les
dents creuses et quand le maire dit
c'est un terrain comme ça c'est pas
constructible mais voilà on ça reste en
l'état donc le fait que les mères les
des petites communes rurales ne soient
pas à même de pouvoir peser et de
pouvoir on en fait pas confiance et ils
sont pas en capacité de pouvoir faire
entendre raison au bureau d'études et à
l'ensemble des autres élus et notamment
certaines communes qui ont des activités
économiques qui sont pas reconnues par
l'interco et qui ont pas de
développement possible ni même de
construction alors qu'elles ont eu un
grand nombre parce que ça aussi ça
existe sur les 10 ans précédant beaucoup
de construction solutions beaucoup de
permis de construire mais pour l'avenir
pas parce qu'on a décidé qu'il y avait
des pôles de proximité etc donc voilà il
y a il y a de grosses difficultés sur la
mise en place de du de ce de cette
diminution par deux et si jamais
qu'est-ce que je reviens sur le 1% parce
que moi je suis sur un territoire où il
y a même sur une petite commune de
200-300 400 habitants il y a un tout
petit bout et puis il y a plein plein de
hameaux autour avec quelques maisons
alors l'enveloppe urbanisée ce serait
quoi est-ce que parce que déjà dans les
pays les petits hameaux où il y a trois
quatre maisons c'est déjà rayé c'est pas
possible on va pas construire là donc
comment fait-on et voilà pour c'est la
prise en compte de ce qu'est la réalité
la réalité de la ruralité
Sonia de la pauvreté
je vais revenir sur les grands projets
d'intérêt
national et sur les projets d'intérêt
général
j'ai posé deux questions en fait
il a été dit les régions ne doivent pas
décider seul je pense que l'État doit
pas décider seul non plus enfin à mon
avis c'est une évidence
et et en même temps faut bien trouver
une instance suffisamment représentative
du point de vue des uns et des autres et
de toutes les tailles de communes et de
toutes les situations finalement
communales et de tous les types de
collectivités pour décider de ce qui
relève du projet d'intérêt national ou
pas
parce que ça peut aller de la prison à
un grand projet économique où au canal
senor dont on parle autant mais qui qui
correspond quand même à une enveloppe de
foncier très importante comment comment
voyez-vous l'organisation qui pourrait
se mettre en place si si par hasard
la somme de tous les projets d'intérêt
national décidé par les uns et les
autres et compris au niveau national par
la somme de tout ça ça dépasse 50% de
l'enveloppe nationale qu'on a consommé
c'est un moment comment vont se faire
les arbitrages parce que ça veut dire
que si on met bout à Boutou là on n'est
pas loin de ça on n'est pas loin de ça
donc ça veut dire qu'il y en a qu'on va
choisir et qu'il y en a qu'on va pas
choisir est-ce qu'on empêche l'état de
construire une prison est-ce qu'on
empêche voilà donc comment à un moment
faut bien qu'il y ait une instance digne
de ce nom et c'est pas une ctape qui va
faire ça et puis ma deuxième question
c'est la même chose pour l'échelon
régional
le foncier c'est du logement c'est de
l'économie c'est de l'infrastructure
sont des équipements etc du point de vue
de la région et dans le stradet il y a
un type économique qui va prendre une
part très importante du foncier et vers
lequel se tourne plein d'exigences y
compris environnementales c'est
l'arrivée des centres de
intermodo de logistique et ça ça
consomme beaucoup beaucoup de fonciers
et les régions sont en train d'envisager
des lieux où on va consommer du foncier
comment comment vous vous voyez
à quel niveau
cette enveloppe va être
prise en compte est-ce que c'est aller
chez l'enfant de la commune
à l'échelon du Scott est-ce que c'est à
l'échelle de l'intercommunalité est-ce
que c'est la région et donc on
re-répartie sur les autres communes et
qui décide et comment
voilà
merci Sonia Cédric Vial puis Jean-Claude
Anglard puis après on va laisser la
parole à nos invités parce que leur fait
plus que tourner oui merci j'avais pas
prévu d'intervenir mais j'ai deux
questions peut-être rapides qui
s'adresse plutôt à vous peut-être madame
Rossignol la première c'est sur les
projets d'intérêt nationaux on l'a dit
tout à l'heure sur la question de la
définition et notamment on était assez
surpris lors d'audition du ministre qui
nous disent que les projets privés ne
pouvaient pas être des projets d'intérêt
nationaux et quel que soit le ampleur
donc est-ce que vous avez un avis
là-dessus sur la définition d'entrepris
et public et deuxièmement on sait tous
qu'il y a aussi des conséquences des
effets collatéraux ces projets SI
admettons qu'on accueille un projet
d'intérêt national et qui soit reconnu
national comprennent sur une enveloppe
qu'elle soit nationale régionale
mutualisée ou pas ici il faut accueillir
1500 ou 2000 salariés comment prend-on
en compte c'est c'est ce besoin de
logement sur des territoires qui peuvent
être gros sur quelle enveloppe les
conséquences de de cela
peut-il être pris si le Scott ne l'avait
pas prévu initialement et deuxième
intervention qui peut être aussi une
forme de question je pense que notre
collègue Cécile quikerman tout à l'heure
on a l'impression effectivement que ce
texte le climat résilience avait parté
d'une intention mais entre l'intention
et la réalisation ou ou l'application on
voit qu'il y a une marche qui est
importante et qui est loin d'être
franchie on a l'impression que ce texte
que l'on est en train de monter cette
PPL
ch cher Jean-Baptiste c'est un peu comme
des médecins qui se penchent autour d'un
patient pour essayer de sauver le
patient mais moi j'ai l'impression qu'il
est déjà mort donc on peut continuer à
réfléchir mais on est dans une logique
où on va mettre en place des
prescriptions à partir de 2028 pour un
objectif à partir de 50% à partir de
2030 or la période couverte à partir
2028 c'est à partir du moment qu'il y
aura des prescriptions on aura déjà
couvert 80 % de la période donc un
rythme logique de 10% par an pour
arriver à 100% sur 10 ans on aura
atteint 80% donc ma question elle est
assez simple madame est-ce que vous
pensez qu'en 2028 quand on va changer
tous les documents des scottes parce
qu'on y arrivera en un an on va changer
tous les scottes et tous les plu c'est
évident une fois qu'on aura fait ça
est-ce que vous pensez qu'il y aura
encore des PLU en 2028 où on pourra
construire ne serait-ce qu'un mètre
carré avant 2030
merci Cédric
Jean-Claude anglar et Patrice Joly qui
s'est manifeste je voulais compléter les
questions qui ont été posées et les
diversifier un
le rapporteur a posé la question de la
zone montagne comment était prise en
compte j'ai pas entendu de réponse
d'aucun des participants en premièrement
et puis deuxièmement plutôt voilà ça
s'adresse au breton présent de la salle
n'est-ce pas la question des bâtiments
agricoles est-ce que aujourd'hui dans
les documents d'urbanisme la question du
bâtiments agricoles n'est pas posée
puisque dans les espaces naturels
agricoles forestiers ce n'est pas des
comté or là on a une interrogation
est-ce que vous avez réfléchi à cette
question là en tout cas elle nous
interroge merci
Jean-Claude Patrice Joly merci madame la
Présidente peut-être souligner parce
qu'il concerne également la sensibilité
politique du sujet ceci arrive après
10 ans 20 ans 30 ans 44 décennies où on
a plutôt travaillé sur la perspective du
développement de la France autour des
centres urbains autour des métropoles
arrive après la mise en place des
stradettes et un certain nombre de
documents normatifs comme les scottes
les pays après une application la plus
récente des du RNU appliqué très
strictement et gênant le les
constructions sur les sur les
territoires ruraux avec des documents
qui ont un problème qui ont un problème
de légitimité parce que un problème de
compréhension c'est complexité
particulière technique souvent
appropriées par quelques élus simplement
celui qui pilote peut-être un ou deux
autour de lui et donc ces problèmes de
compréhension à la fois de ces documents
de leurs enjeux et donc dès lors un
problème d'acceptabilité du sens même si
on n'est pas d'accord on peut comprendre
le sens d'un certain nombre de
dispositifs dire on n'aurait pas fait ça
on n'a pas la même perspective on l'en
comprend le sens et la question elle est
là aujourd'hui cette question légitimité
m'a paraît majeure parce que
effectivement il y a un manque de
maîtrise de la part des élus qui à qui
cela s'impose et puis j'ai entendu aussi
c'est amusant d'ailleurs par les par
celui qui décède ces propos là dire mais
à la fin les communes dans toutes ces
instances là rurales sont majoritaires
et celui qui nous dit ça à l'instant et
ben c'est le maire de la commune centre
qui est président de la communauté de
communes vraisemblablement qui a la
compétence en matière d'urbanisme et la
réalité elle est là c'est à dire
effectivement le nombre des communes
rurales est là mais derrière sont quand
même et ça dépend mon plus complètement
légitime les représentants les
principales communes alors qu'est-ce que
font les élus ruraux ça a été dit leur
manière de dire qu'il se trouve qui ne
s'y retrouve pas mais ils ne viennent
pas aux réunions ils ne viennent plus ou
moins en moins et ça c'était quand même
c'est un sujet qui est devant nous et
qui s'ajoute à des pro blématiques comme
de santé sur nos territoires etc et je
vous laisse aller au bout de la des
conséquences et notamment dans la
traduction politique que l'on a vu ces
dernières années que l'on risque de voir
malheureusement se renforcer dans les
années qui viennent
je voudrais simplement revenir sur la
question de la garantie et du droit au
développement ça a été évoqué avant moi
et à un droit accueillir également des
des populations et surtout un droit à
construire pour les populations
autochtones aujourd'hui qui ont vu
autour d'eux à Marchi mobilier au cours
des deux dernières années complètement
asséchés alors que le parcours d'accès
au logement sur le territoire regarde
des moyens financiers de nos populations
on achète une maison à la rénov
progressivement et le risque aujourd'hui
avec cette asséchement des marchés de
l'immobilier et bien c'est de ne plus
avoir cette possibilité donc la question
quand même de la possibilité de
construire pour les populations
autochtones est un vrai sujet lorsqu'on
dit la garantie du 1 ha je crois que ça
peut concerner à peu près selon la un
certain nombre
les éléments qu'on peut prendre en
compte mais en gros 22000 communes 22000
communes c'est 22000 hectares 22000
hectares on ne sait très bien que c'est
22 000 hectares ne seront pas utilisés
en quelques-uns au mieux il y en aura un
ça veut dire on va être à 6000 hectares
6000 hectares sur 55 millions d'hectares
qui est la surface métropolitaine de
notre pays sur à peu près 120 000
hectares qu'on envisage comme étant le
niveau de construction c'est Epsilon sur
la question que c'est pas d'identifier
aujourd'hui c'est surfaces telles
qu'elles pour être artificialisée mais
c'est trouver un moyen d'une gestion
expost effectivement de ce qui sera
effectivement réalisé et là pour le coup
de manière cohérente en donnant la
possibilité dans une période donnée à
des élus qui verraient sur leur
territoire que la consommation ne
s'ouvre pas éventuellement d'échanger
avec des collègues sont situés à 5 à 10
à 20 km sur des projets et là on aurait
quelques jours tout ce qui aurait à voir
avec une relation
comment de coopération au sein d'un
stance intercommunal voilà merci
mes chers collègues alors qui
prend la parole pour essayer de réagir
en tout cas à ces différentes
interventions et aux questions de notre
rapporteur qui s'y risquent François
descoeurs
oui madame la Présidente cette deuxième
partie de réunion moi m'a plutôt fait
plaisir parce que on sait en faire rendu
compte qu'il y avait des maires
qui avaient des mers qui avaient envie
d'être attendu qui avait envie d'être
respecté et avec bienveillance
certes les maires il y a des petits mers
c'est pas une histoire de de taille mais
pour autant
toute cette loi doit reposer sur le
départ effectivement du maire et de sa
commune et même si c'est une commune qui
est toute petite et là franchement les
dernières intervenants qui sont
intervenus la sur ce sujet là
vont dans un sens qui ne peut que nous
satisfaire alors c'est vrai qu'après
tout à l'heure monsieur goodbel vous
dira un mot pour terminer mais en tant
que amrf mais
je pense que
c'est important quand même de bien
prendre en considération ceci et de de
bien de bien les intégrer à toutes les
réflexions c'est ce que vous faites on
vous en remercie et d'ailleurs on vous
fera passer parce que nous travaillons
depuis longtemps de sur les sujets on va
vous faire passer dès demain
une pièce écrite sur sur l'ensemble des
réponses que qui permettra de figer un
petit peu le raisonnement et ce qui nous
concerne tous du moins et voilà je
voulais je voulais me permettre de
rajouter ce mot parce que les élus
ruraux ont besoin d'être entendus et
considéré voilà
merci beaucoup monsieur desker
rurale et ben effectivement revenir à la
définition de l'Insee 2020 de ce qu'est
la ruralité me semble absolument
nécessaire et obligatoire donc ce serait
parfait dans ce sens-là une garantie de
réserve pour une solidarité territoriale
et là aussi qu'elle puisse être fléchée
cette solidarité territoriale en faveur
des plus démunis de sous-entends la
ruralité mais peut-être que ça pourrait
être fléché au niveau des zones de
revitalisation d'erreur des territoires
clichés en ZRR et qui ont besoin de
requalification de développement
économique de service et ça pourrait
être un bon sens que ce soit fléchés
vers ces territoires là qui vient un peu
compléter ce qu'est la ruralité
et si on change pas effectivement
l'approche si on cale tout sur ce qui
s'est passé depuis les 10 dernières
années et ben globalement on change pas
aménagement du territoire donc ceux qui
ont fait beaucoup auront encore droit
beaucoup et là aussi je pour compléter
ce que dit mon collègue François desker
sur le jeu et l'exercice de dire on
passe du 1 hectare à 1%. et ben 1% pour
toutes les communes Lyon c'est 47
hectares et Murol c'est un hectare en
arghien à ce que vous proposez mais
voyez bien qu'on est aussi les villes
ont tellement explosé les métropoles ont
tellement explosé que là aussi c'est
vraiment donné un blanc sain aux villes
les plus importantes et aux métropoles
qui en plus derrière et je n'ai rien
contre ça je ne pose pas les territoires
dans toute l'ingénierie administrative
et financière pour justifier des besoins
de développement économique accrus et
encore plus vite sur la reconté des
espaces et des choses de ce type là donc
voilà sur cette cette première réponse
cette réponse de conclusion madame la
Présidente merci de m'avoir écouté merci
beaucoup monsieur Gouttebel monsieur
Miossec on termine par Madame Rossignol
si vous voulez bien
pardon alors j'ai bien senti que mon
intervention sur le PLU intercommunal
avait avait
fait réagir et justement j'ai bien fait
attention tout à l'heure de d'abord de
parler du PLU d'abord le PLU c'est la
commune c'est la liberté de la commune
de me faire son PLU
et de je suggérais de le penser à une
échelle intercommunale parce que de mon
point de vue comme d'ailleurs dans
beaucoup d'endroits c'est l'occasion de
penser à un développement de territoire
à l'échelle du bassin de vie moi je suis
pas mère d'une ville centre pour
répondre aussi au sénateur Joly je suis
mère de la 6ème commune sur 16 donc je
suis au milieu de tableau ni trop grand
ni trop petit et d'ailleurs je vous
invite
alors et justement j'allais dire j'ai
pas le document sous les yeux mais
interco de France a fait une étude
justement sur les 1200 et quelques
présidents et présidents interco et ben
on est j'ai pu en tête le pourcentage
mais je vous donnerai le chiffre tout à
l'heure en à la fin de notre édition si
vous le souhaitez mais il y a une part
je dirais pas loin de la moitié des
présidents et présents qui sont pas élus
de la ville centre j'ai même pas ma mère
aussi des
alors ce qui est mais historiquement
c'était le cas il y a pas personne dire
à l'inverse historiquement et la la
culture populaire pense que c'est plutôt
le spontanément ouais on dirait c'est
plutôt le maire de la ville centre qui
est président mais dans la dans les
fesses c'est pas forcément le pas
forcément le cas
même si ça reste majeur voilà je vais
pas dire l'inverse non plus et puis et
puis
quand je quand on parlait de majorité je
ne nie pas que le pouvoir des des
grandes communes on va dire des des
communes urbaines dans les
intercommunalités et fort
notamment dans la composition des
conseils communautaires je sais que ça a
fait débat au Sénat aussi il y a
quelques temps mais sur la matière
justement du PLU intercommunal la façon
dont ça s'élabore un PLU avec la charte
de gouvernance avec la les étapes d'avis
de validation
par les conseils municipaux et par le
conseil communautaire il y a une telle
comment dire c'était le tel dispositif
que je redis clairement les petites
communes ont capacité à bloquer un PLU
donc la madame la sénatrice du Lot je
crois si j'ai bien noté un moment si les
bureaux d'études ne respectent pas les
communes et ben il faut que le moment
qu'elle fasse remonter par la
gouvernance qui a été prévu dans le PMU
que ça ne va pas que ça ne marche pas et
qu'à la fin des fins si elle veut de
contre le paix-lui il n'aboutira pas il
y a des il y a des dispositifs non mais
c'est Madame là c'est la triste Carmen
c'est là théorie c'est ça
mais
partout comme ça je mais vous savez
comme moi que sur la taille de
l'intercommunalité selon les compris les
déformations entre le poids d'un certain
nombre de communes très urbaines ou
rurales la réalité dans la gouvernance
quoi je veux dire qu'on n'est pas en
train de révéler un scoop il y a plein
de choses
non dites il y a des relations qui
rendent les choses bien plus complexes
que ça quoi et donc se dire c'est aussi
fluide que ce que vous dites je pense
ça ne va pas bien partout je dis bien
j'assume j'ai pas de souci ça ne va pas
bien partout mais je ne je ne peux pas
entendre non plus que ça va mal partout
et que je pense que c'est un peu une loi
de HP 80 20 90 10 certes il y a
peut-être dit souvent des endroits où ça
va pas bien
parce que la gouvernance est pas posée
c'est souvent d'ailleurs une question de
femme et d'hommes et pas une question de
texte de loi ou de etc bon faut que les
personnes acceptent de travailler
ensemble et ils mettent des choses en
commun mais la vraie vie de nos
territoires quand on vous fait un pays
pourquoi le nom de la fait chez nous
parce qu'à un moment on vit on travaille
on fait ses études on a ses loisirs dans
plusieurs communes un moment de penser
les mobilités de penser l'habitat de
penser les entreprises à une autre
échelle que ça strict échelle communale
je pense que c'est un peu de sens bon
cela dit et je reviens au cœur du sujet
de cet après-midi mais quand je dis donc
de réfléchir via Lausanne c'est parce
que quand on regarde les hameaux du lot
qui peuvent ressembler à la
l'urbanisation Bretagne qui est très
très dispersée mais c'est pas du tout
vrai dans d'autres régions de France
donc un moment justement comment une loi
l'échelle nationale peut définir
clairement des choses qui vont répondre
l'autre répondent au Finistère mais
répondre à pas répondre à tel ou telle
autre département parce que je connais
pas bien les hauts de France mais je
crois que l'urbanisation elle est
beaucoup plus concentrée autour de
autour de Bourg voilà même tout petit
même de quelques dizaines ou quelques
centaines d'habitants mais il y a moins
d'habitat disperser donc c'est de pas
partout et ben voilà ça dépend et c'est
pour ça et c'est pour ça que je pense
qu'à un moment on ne peut pas définir
d'en haut des règles qui répondront et
cochons et que je compte tous les cases
partout et donc le foncier je reprends
ma conclusion de mon propos introductif
le foncier c'est un peu comme l'argent
aujourd'hui c'est une valeur qui est
finie qui qu'il faut se partager qu'il
faut apprendre à gérer ensemble et et
elle est comment dire il y a une telle
hétérogénéité de nos territoires qu'il
faut laisser de la souplesse locale et
un moment je vous choque peut-être mais
le pluie c'est le moins mauvais endroit
où on a réussi à se partager un foncier
et je redis si dans un territoire il y a
admettons 50 communes il y a 25 communes
qui n'ont rien qui n'ont pas de foncier
bon courage pour faire aboutir le pluie
ça marchera pas c'est un ça sera pas
adopté même si c'est adopté par là je
quel moyen ça ne fonctionnera pas dans
la durée donc un moment le pari de la
confiance de la liberté locale on parie
tous on est souvent apprenez la liberté
locale c'est de laisser les territoires
se gérer sur cette base là juste
peut-être il y avait deux trois
questions précises je vais très vite les
bâtiments agricoles c'est un sujet alors
qui est dans la première phase de des
dix premières années justement très
posées puisque c'est pas de la
consommation d'espace ceinture agricole
et forestier parce que ça relève du
monde agricole là où dans 10 ans ça sera
de l'artificialisation et ça peut ça
peut relever de de volume plus que
significatif voilà selon les territoires
là aussi selon les types de production
agricoles selon la dixième agricole sur
les territoires en Bretagne on cite
souvent les poulailler qui a la
production de de poulet à s'effondrer
donc on a d'immenses bâtiments de
plusieurs milliers de mètres carrés
parfois qui sont fermés et abandonnés
donc c'est c'est des vrais c'est pas ça
peut être des gisements importants mais
comment et comme un qui paye etc
et puis bon je m'arrête là parce que
j'étais déjà
merci Madame Rossignol moi je voudrais
préciser le cas dans lequel nous avons
travaillé la Fédération des scottes
comme dans beaucoup de conférences des
scottes c'est qu'on est rentré dans le
cadre de la loi telle qu'elle avait été
votée et que nous avons essayé de jouer
notre rôle dans le cadre de cette loi
c'est à dire que nous n'avons pas
cherché à
repenser notre système de gouvernement
local et que finalement dans le système
d'aujourd'hui le Scott et le lieu où les
élus communaux les élus intercommunaux
sont amenés à travailler ensemble sur
les questions d'aménagement du
territoire et c'est donc c'est dans ce
cadre là que nous avons essayé de
travailler même si bon je préside un
Scott de 2006 communes si on sait bien
que la communication que la le travail
est extrêmement difficile parce qu'on
est sur des documents techniques sur
lequel il est parfois
difficile d'intéresser chacun des mers
mais où on sait très bien que au bout du
compte quand les décisions deviennent
opérationnelles chaque maire va être
concernée au premier chef puisque c'est
lui-même qui va aller devoir porter les
décisions auprès de sa population donc
ça c'est un vrai souci que nous portons
tous mais dans le travail nous sommes
restés dans le cadre de la loi il nous a
semblé effectivement le Scott
aujourd'hui dans le cadre de nos
institutions et le lieu de travail sur
la répartition et qu'il y en a pas
aujourd'hui d'autres et que
l'alternative qui est quand même que
l'État a essayé de prendre en charge les
ânes et même de l'appliquer avant même
que les conférences de Scott a eu le
temps de travailler il y a quand même eu
un certain nombre de difficultés dans un
certain nombre de régions entre les
préfets préfet de région et les
intercommunalités pour
empêcher une application
unilatérale de la loi avant même que
elle était discutée véritablement donc
ça c'est un premier point après sur les
points
qui ont été plus précis qui ont été
posées oui pour les enveloppes
donnezoscope parce qu'il nous semble que
c'est dans le cadre des scottes
qu'effectivement on va pouvoir amener la
discussion pour se répartir les efforts
et je pense que la question du droit
minimum de chacune des communes rurales
en général dans l'école dans les
conférences des scottes étaient
peut-être le sujet le sujet de
discussion
comment arriver à garantir à chacun donc
il y a des hypothèses différentes qui
ont été présentées aux régions mais ça a
été un sujet majeur donc oui pour les
zones oui très bien pour les zones de
densification à traiter à traiter dans
le cadre de des trajectoires que les
scottes se fixent
très bien et ça c'était une chose sur
lequel nous avions
particulièrement travaillé dans les
hauts de France c'était la question du
très côte ça a été repris et ça me
paraît extrêmement important
après
l'hectare nous choque mais le droit
minimal de chaque commune qui doit être
assurée dans le cadre des Scott oui tout
à fait c'est à dire chaque commune doit
avoir un droit à se développer en
fonction des besoins et des besoins de
ses besoins à elle et des besoins du
territoire
sur la question publique privée dans le
cadre des projets nationaux la question
honnêtement la fédération de ces même
pas posée il nous a paru c'est une
évidence est-ce qu'on va faire la
différence enfin je veux dire les 100
hectares sur Airbus à Toulouse est-ce
que c'est sur le compte de la commune
concernée je pense que non je pense bien
que c'est un compte national et que
enfin voilà ça nous a paru ça nous a
paru comme
notre position nous elle a été celle là
elle nous c'est-à-dire que ce qui fait
le côté national c'est
l'ampleur du projet son rayonnement et
son n'est pas son statut et que donc ça
effectivement ça demande ce qu'on est
une organisation sur l'établissement de
la liste mais on a eu les mêmes
réflexions sur les projets dirigeonnants
à quel niveau parce que et là
effectivement la différence dans un
petit dans un territoire rural le lycée
peut être un équipement régional en
Île-de-France le lycée n'est peut-être
pas dans une commune de plus de 100000
habitants n'est peut-être pas un
équipement de nature régionale et donc
la fabrique du territoire et la nature
des équipements leur importance fait que
la définition d'une région à une autre
ne sera peut-être pas exactement la même
de ce qui est d'intérêt régional alors
il y avait d'autres questions peut-être
que j'ai oublié il me semble que non
mais
je ne sais pas s'il y a je pense
une entreprise comment compter
l'enveloppe foncière nécessaire pour
là honnêtement on n'avait pas imaginé
que ça puisse faire partie du compte
national parce qu'elle a après on est
sur du développement
non mais parce que si
il y a de la création d'emplois
le scotch prévoit une enveloppe comme
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le Scott prévoit
une enveloppe de territoire de zones
constructibles si on est amené à avoir
un équipement qui fait exploser le Scott
il faut il faut modifier le scotch c'est
une modification de ce code de même que
vous auriez une modification de plus ou
de poste si vous arriviez au bout
excusez-moi mais aujourd'hui le Scott si
effectivement il y a un projet national
ou important vous pouvez modifier le
scotch en rajoutant x MX hectares et en
rajoutant aux communes aux communes
concernées des capacités de construire
pour accueillir les habitants
aujourd'hui c'est possible avec une
procédure qui est validée par l'État
demain vous pourrez plus c'est une
enveloppe fermée donc vous allez donc ce
que vous allez remettre vous allez le
prendre
une enveloppe supplémentaire si vraiment
un projet fait exploser le document et
fait exploser les chiffres ça veut dire
qu'il faut qu'une réflexion soit
régionale soit nationale pour prendre en
compte ce projet mais au niveau régional
l'enveloppe est fermé donc si on vous
rajoute si on donne au Scott il faut
qu'on enlève le code voisin et donc on
va demander une révision d'un Scott dans
la Loire pour le relever 10 hectares
pour les donner département de l'Isère
parce qu'il y aura un projet dans le
département libre mais vous pensez que
c'est possible je ne le demande pas
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
possible c'est pas question est-ce que
vous pensez que c'est possible
à l'échelle d'une région
ce serait envisageable je veux dire
enfin je veux dire dans notre dans notre
conférence des scotch on a commencé à
aborder les questions d'échanges
en termes de renaturation par exemple il
y a des territoires qui nous ont dit
nous on a énormément de friches et on
peut renaturer
et voilà mais si on remet nature pour
vous comment est-ce qu'on peut échanger
c'est des questions ouvertes mais c'est
des questions qui ont pu commencer à se
poser
parce que effectivement les territoires
sont différents et donc ce sont des
territoires qui nous ont posé ces
questions ils ont dit nous on a
peut-être pas on est peut-être plus
éloigné de certaines voies de
communication c'est peut-être pas vers
nous que viendrons un certain nombre de
grandes installations industrielles mais
c'est des questions qui sont ouvertes et
qui se posent à partir de la loi et que
et que sur le territoire il faudra
pouvoir se poser mais on n'a pas la
solution c'est pas nous qui veut dire je
ne suis pas le législateur du tout
merci Madame fourneau je ne sais pas si
vous êtes encore là parce qu'on ne voit
pas à l'image donc si vous êtes là
évidemment vous êtes invité à vous
exprimer
et on serait heureux
oui vous m'entendez oui oui oui allez-y
je vous en prie madame fourneau
sur les questions de ruralité juste pour
vous confirmer que la NF est extrêmement
sensible évidemment à la question de des
communes rurales puisque c'est quand
même notre point central
de réflexion d'autant que la
composition de la NF était voilà 80%
qu'on faisait de communes rurale donc
c'est vraiment le sens de nos réflexions
sur tous nos groupes de travail et
commissions notamment la Commission des
Communautés territoire euro c'est une
question qui revient systématiquement la
question de la prise en compte usane et
de laisser qui impliquerait justement
une application extrêmement je dirais
pulvérisé
faire démographique sur les communes
rurales donc ça c'est vraiment un point
d'attention particulier c'est le sens
justement du recours quand on demande la
prise en compte des efforts passés au
niveau régional et
pas seulement Scott c'est le sens
effectivement de tout le travail sur
l'application et l'adaptation d'usane
aux communes les plus isolées dans le
cadre des erreurs donc c'est vraiment un
enjeu primordial pour la nature juste je
voulais que ce soit très clair
c'est clair dans dans les questions qui
ont été posées simplement et donc et
donc c'est évidemment la façon dont on
va appliquer cette trajectoire âme qui
va finalement garantir ou non une
capacité de développement aux communes
rural plus l'application se dispositif
et de ses trajectoires se fait de
manière très
descendante et donc tu t'élèves comme
cela était évoqué plus effectivement
la façon dont les territoires notamment
les plus ruraux les moins dynamiques
vont le ressentir sera pénalisante donc
finalement tout notre travail ça a été
justement de s'assurer et comme vous
l'avez fait aussi dans le fait du Sénat
que que la trajectoire s'appliquera dans
un rapport extrêmement souple entre le
niveau régional et le bloc local et
s'assurer qu'au niveau du bloc local une
gouvernance satisfaisante existe à
travers des commissions de consignation
renforcées des documents d'urbanisme et
un débat très très clair avec le préfet
sur des notes d'enjeux des chiffres
justement on est sur la table l'ensemble
des projets on réfléchit ensemble et on
continue à faire travailler la
conférence de scotch c'est une
conférence au sens de celle du Sénat
effectivement ce serait aussi favorable
avec des groupes de travail élargi aussi
aux communes et aux interprés de
débattre donc c'est vraiment cette
capacité de débattre avec une
trajectoire la plus la plus entre
guillemets adaptable possible dans les
communes et les intercos qui vont devoir
appliquer cette trajectoire à travers
les scottes les PLU et les cartes
communales y compris les communes ont
rénu parce qu'on parle pas des
communions évidemment elles seront
touchées de fait par l'effet des vases
communicants de des trajectoiresales
donc voilà sous l'enjeu pour nous
tout en atteignant l'objectif à 0 à 2050
mais avec toute cette souplesse pour
adapter les objectifs et garantir cette
capacité de développement du territoire
européens voilà ça répond aux articles 7
et 8 je pense l'article 9 effectivement
si monsieur le sénateur gland soit des
précisions sur le décret en cours de
révision sur la nomenclature des seuls
artificialisés effectivement
ce décret est en cours de réécriture et
avec toute une réflexion sur les
échelles et on nous a bien fait
comprendre que ce décret n'avait
vocation finalement qu'à classer les
sols entre guillemets entre les sols dit
artificialisés et non artificialisée et
à pouvoir justement
concrétiser le fameux soldes pour autant
obtenir le chiffre net d'artifialisation
des sols et qu'il n'empêchait pas
finalement et qui était indépendant de
la notion de constructivité des sols et
qu'un seul même s'il était non
artificialisé restez constructive dès
lors que le PLU ou la carte communale le
prévoyait dans son projet de territoire
donc ça c'est une précision importante
de manière la plus importante possible
compatible l'ensemble des données sur
l'observation des sols qui soient de la
consommation d'espace ou à
l'artificialisation des sols pour aller
faire que les données locales existantes
qui soient les plus à jour puissent
alimenter les données régionales voire
locale voire nationale pardon et que
l'ensemble de ces données se répondent
pour qu'on puisse parler finalement d'un
d'une même dans voilà sur des mêmes
bases de réflexion et finalement
s'entendre sur ce dont on parle voilà
c'est un peu la réflexion globale de
l'AMF je voulais vous le préciser voilà
à titre technique voilà
merci Madame fourneau si vous le voulez
bien je donne la parole à Christian
Redon sarrazzi qui souhaitait s'exprimer
c'est dommage on aime Roussillon vient
de partir mais je crois que le sujet est
important puisqu'on voit qu'il remonte
de plus en plus le problème des friches
où sont-elles sous quel sous quel à qui
appartient-elle sont-elles propriétés de
l'État ou d'autres
collectivités ou de particuliers de
quelle qualité
a-t-on un inventaire de ces friches
quantitatifs et qualitatif et
comment va-t-on traiter ce problème là
parce que est-ce qu'on va être en place
un marché des friches comme on a un
marché carbone enfin on voit bien que ça
commence
plus on avance plus on avance et plus le
sujet j'ai l'impression prends de la de
l'importance dans le dans peut-être pas
dans les deux arbres mais dans les
merci merci Christian Jean-Baptiste pour
conclure pardon pardon monsieur
mais qui est fini par définition les
friches enfin on en créera probablement
petit à petit mais par définition de
moins en moins donc c'est une solution
mais de transition donc tout ça ça nous
amène vers une une un but final qui est
quand même c'est si le zan n'existe
vraiment un jour je suis je pense que la
question comment reste ouverte soit
vraiment du zan dans 30 ans mais en tout
cas on aura une fois qu'on aura consommé
tous les potentialités ça fait grand
chose
très rapide pour laisser Jean-Baptiste
sur les friches parce que je pense que
vous avez raison justement parce que
d'abord elles sont connues on aurait
besoin d'en avoir une vraie cartographie
et en tout cas se dire que dans un
certain nombre de territoires aussi
parce qu'on ne les a pas requalifié pour
plein de raisons
comme mademoiselle voilà on a aussi
consommé et et construite d'autres
modèles d'aménagement du territoire mais
le un des vrais enjeux quand même en
tout cas pour l'instant serait aussi si
déjà on requalifié tout ça pour remettre
des services publics privés sur ces
friches on pourrait peut-être repenser
les enjeux d'usane et donc du foncier
agricole et naturel
avec un autre regard que celui qui nous
a imposé aujourd'hui simplement par de
la requalification à N + 10 ou plus 12
merci Cécile
y a-t-il des des remarques
complémentaires
Jean-Baptiste un petit mot de conclusion
peut-être par rapport à tous ces
échanges
merci Madame en conclusion c'est aussi
une conclusion de remerciements tous nos
invités et tous les intervenants les
collègues qui sont intervenus je crois
qu'il y a eu des questionnaires donc il
faut pas que nous inviter hésitent à
faire des réponses écrites qui dit bon
nous aider toujours plus à réfléchir
vous avez compris quels sont les points
durs c'est à dire le délai d'un an à
d'ici demain et non sinon c'est pas
drôle oui c'est ça demain
les commissions les arbitrages
dépôts de délai de dépôt vendredi pour
la que les amendements de commission et
c'est le 12 pour les amendements de
séance je pense 10 pour les amendements
de séance
voilà donc sur le délai d'un an sur le
caractère prescriptif du stradet sur la
gouvernance qu'on soit le plus précis
possible sur le droit à l'hectare enfin
surtout ces sujets là on a besoin de
position toujours plus précise ça va ça
va nous aider et effectivement je
terminerai avec l'intervention de
Christian Redon sarrazzi les friches
c'est un sujet énorme et il y a pas
beaucoup de transparence sur ce sujet on
sait juste qu'il y a 200 000 hectares à
peu près mais quand quoi ou comment et
voilà et sans compter le financement
qui suivra ce sujet et la nouvelle
fiscalité
sur ces friches c'est vrai que si les
services de l'État étant en mesure de
nous apporter quelques éléments de
précision sur la nature de toutes ces
friches leur enclavement ou au contraire
leur proximité d'infrastructure ça
changerait aussi ça nous donnerait une
capacité effectivement à mesurer ce
qu'on est en capacité de faire et que ce
sujet est quand même majeur et une
grande inconnue
ce que je vous propose c'est de conclure
maintenant nos débats de remercier à mon
tour tout toutes celles et tous ceux qui
ont participé
à cette audition remercie tous les
représentants des collectivités qui nous
ont éclairé en tout cas de leur
réflexion de leur remarque
toutes les propositions rapides que vous
pourrez nous faire sont les bienvenus et
puis pour notre part et bien on est dans
la dernière ligne droite et
voilà on a quelques réunions
d'importance qui nous attendent dans les
jours qui viennent et sur lesquels nous
aurons des arbitrages importants à faire
donc
réfléchissez bien parce que tout ce
qu'on vient d'échanger encore et
d'entendre ont été éclairants à
plus d'un point de vue
je vous souhaite bon courage et je nous
souhaite bon courage parce que là la
tâche est importante et tellement
essentiel pour nos territoires et
tellement attendu pour ne pas nous élus
locaux alors je vous souhaite bonne
soirée
la prochaine réunion sera
l'établissement du texte de la
commission et donc l'horaire c'est
voilà mercredi 8 mars
mercredi 8 mars 16h30 il reste des
auditions mais pas en plénière ce sont
des auditions rapporteurs auxquelles on
peut s'associer des uns les autres mais
en tout cas la prochaine réunion
plénière portera bien sur
l'établissement du texte de commission
voilà
bon courage à tous merci et à très vite